Almost Heaven, older Twitch Chat, all these emotes, wondering how to spell that.
Now we're all ones moved on, but I remember Twitch Chat from those days that are gone.
Twitch emotes, long ago, made you feel like a punk champ, keep a forehead, Bible thumb, Twitch emotes, typing Dan's game, forehead swift rage, PJ Salt and Balefish.
Twitch emotes.
TOS was nowhere, so everyone's feeling fine, Twitch emotes, long ago, made you feel like a punk champ, keep a forehead, Bible thumb, Twitch emotes.
I still hear his bark in the morning hour, he calls me.
His doggy emote reminds me of a time far away, looking at a chat, I get a feeling that I miss emotes from yesterday, yesterday.
Twitch emotes, long ago, made you feel like a punk champ, keep a forehead, Bible thumb, Twitch emotes.
Papiливо, Twitch emotes, Puppe hands, Twitch emotes, Bible thumb, Twitch emotes.
So, geht schon los hier
Monka-Corona
capitsext
Kann man auf Twitch eigentlich kein Auto-play mehr ausschalten?
E selatschreud
Ich meine auf YouTube kein Auto-play.
Epidemioloid, Obat.
kann man auf YouTube kein Autoplay mehr ausschalten?
Früher gab es hier immer
Früher gab es hier
immer einen Button, wo man sagen kann,
kein Autoplay.
Wo ist der hin?
Oben rechts, ja?
Wo? Muss ich vielleicht kleiner machen?
Echt, man kann Autoplay nicht
mehr ausschalten?
Das ist echt Fail.
Bist in einer Playlist.
Das heißt, wenn ich die Liste weg mache, dann
sollte der auch, na gut, dann
Ah, ah, okay.
Okay, wir können als nächstes
abspielen.
S-Clap Right Version.
Ich weiß nicht, ob wir das jetzt
Twitch zumuten können. Was ist das?
Oh, Gott.
Twitch hat schon so seine eigenen
äh, seine eigene
Welt irgendwie kreiert, mittlerweile.
Oh, Mann.
Gibt's auch Left Version?
Oh, oh, je. Fang nicht an, ey.
Oh, Mann.
So, Leute, also.
Seid ihr wach?
Also offensichtlich, sonst wärt ihr ja
nicht im Stream.
Das heißt, ich kann jetzt eigentlich wieder ausmachen.
Ich bin ja mal gespannt, ob heute
von der Arbeit,
also da, wo ich arbeite, ob da heute
noch irgendeine Mail kommt,
wie es mit nächste Woche
Corona in Frankfurt, wie sieht's denn aus?
Corona Frankfurt.
Kein Fußball, kaum Kultur.
Juckt mich beides nicht.
Flaut am Flughafen juckt mich auch nicht.
Dass ein Museum, das Museen und
der Zoo geschlossen hat, juckt mich auch nicht.
Kein Unterricht am Motor, das weiß ich schon.
Na, vielleicht irgendwas Neues?
Kaum Kultur wie immer, sei ja.
Deswegen juckt mich das auch nicht.
Corona.
Vorbote des Klimawandels.
Okay, man kann auch Sachen miteinander in Zusammenhang bringen,
die jetzt auf den ersten Blick wenig miteinander zu tun haben.
Mein Gott,
jetzt sind die Leute bescheuert.
Alter, haben die Leute Probleme, ey.
Virus, Fernsehessen, Fernsehangst
im Alltag, Angst und Alltag
in Zeiten von Corona.
Was ist mit den Leuten los?
Sag mal, dann wundert mich echt nichts mehr, ja.
Wenn den Leuten nichts anderes einfällt,
außer Fernsehen, Essen zu,
zu essen und Fernsehen zu gucken,
dann, dann, weil, dann ist,
dann ist vorbei, ja.
Übrigens, wollt ihr mal ein absolutes
Cringe-Video sehen, wo wir gerade bei
öffentlich-rechtlichen Medien sind?
Wollt ihr mal ein absolutes,
absolutes Cringe-Video sehen?
Geht auch, geht auch nur 3 Minuten 30.
Oder ist, oder ist es noch zu früh dafür?
Ja, stimmt, Telekom-Beiträge sind nicht so...
Ja, T-Online-Bei...
Das ist, das ist, das überhaupt noch gibt, die Seite.
Weil, weil, weil selbst
verkauft ja die Telekom unter T-Online gar nichts mehr.
T-Online gibt's ja an sich gar nicht mehr.
Genau, die haben, es gibt noch nicht mal,
es gibt noch nicht mal mehr neue,
oder wollen sie nicht mal neue,
neue T-Online-Mail-Adressen haben?
Leute, ich sag euch,
denen fehlt einfach die Magenta-DNA.
Oder, wie, was hatten sie sonst letztens noch?
Die Magenta-DNA und, und,
und YesWeCanMagenta oder sowas?
Die haben doch so übelst doofe Sprüche gehabt.
Ja, wir gucken jetzt jetzt mal das,
das, das, das wurde mir gestern Abend
auf dem Tablet empfohlen, ne?
Übrigens, Leute, ich hab's, ich hab's,
ich hab's gemacht, ich hab mir noch ein iPad bestellt.
Ein neues, ein 7er.
Ja, iPad.
Ich war, ich war ein bisschen mal,
ein bisschen am überlegen.
Also, einen Pro hol ich mir garantiert nicht.
Viel zu teuer.
Einen Air, äh, weiß ich nicht, wozu?
Äh, ein ganz normales.
3, 379, das ist, das ist mittlerweile ein bisschen größer.
Das hat, glaube ich, jetzt 10,2 Zoll.
Das alte hatte 9,7 Zoll.
Äh, ich hab mir schon überlegt,
ob ich mir nicht ein Mini holen soll,
weil eigentlich will ich ja was Kleines,
um, um Streams und, und Videos und Zeug im Bett zu gucken abends.
Woanders für was verwende ich das ja selten.
Ähm, weil,
ich hab mich ja bisher immer rumgeschlagen
mit Android-Tablets,
die halt, wo ich gedacht habe,
ich mach halt besonders Budget, Budget-Varianten.
Sag mal, gute Android-Tablets gibt's eh,
sag mal, wenig, ja.
Ich hab mir mal von Asus eins gekauft.
Das war nicht viel günstiger als ein iPad.
Das hat auch irgendwie 300 Euro oder 350 Euro gekostet.
Und die haben einfach den Support,
die haben nicht ein Update rausgebracht von Asus.
Und das Gerät an sich,
von der Bedienung her, war auch für'n Arsch.
So.
Und, ähm,
so gern ich meine Android-Geräte für irgendwelche Hack-Geschichten habe,
wo man halt die Dinger umbauen kann für alles Mögliche,
geht's mir auf den Sack.
Das Letzte, was ich aktuell benutze, ist ein Fire HD 8.
Ähm,
also nicht geflasht, aber,
das wollte ich nochmal ausprobieren,
aber das kann ich nicht on-stream machen.
Also ich glaube, Amazon mag das nicht,
wenn man quasi auf ihrer Streaming-Plattform zeigt,
wie man Amazon-Tablets flasht.
Ähm,
und, ähm,
das verwende ich aktuell mit einem deploaded,
deploaded Fire OS.
Die Sache ist bloß die,
dass das so nervig ist,
dass sich da immer wieder Sachen aktivieren,
dass der Menü-Button verschwindet,
dass man nicht mehr in die Settings kommt,
dass, ähm,
der Amazon-Launcher sich wieder aktiviert und sowas.
Einfach ätzend.
Ja.
Deswegen habe ich mir gedacht, weißt du was,
ähm,
ich kaufe mir jetzt einfach ein iPad.
Easy.
Kommen wir eigentlich auf die Battlefield-Top-Lays.
Ja.
Ich habe vor, oder ich sage mal, ich hatte vor,
ich hatte vor,
ähm,
heute das Video aufzunehmen
und wahrscheinlich sogar heute Abend hochzuladen.
Ähm,
aber ich brauche so die, die passende,
die passende Motivation dafür.
Da ich sage, jetzt geht's los.
Ja.
Ähm,
leider, leider gab es letzte Woche nicht wirklich viele neue Clips.
Nur einen, den ich auf jeden Fall verwenden werde
und der ist aber nur 25 Sekunden lang.
Ich muss gucken, dass ich dann ein ordentliches,
am besten Viertelstunden-Video zusammenkriege,
weil das wäre schon cool.
Und jetzt habe ich wieder ein neues.
Übrigens,
wenn ihr ein iPad bestellt,
nochmal ein Tipp an der Stelle.
Ich weiß gar nicht, ob man das hier jetzt überhaupt sieht.
Wenn ihr ein iPad bestellt,
dann dürft ihr auf keinen Fall,
ich klicke jetzt mal irgendwas an,
weil ich weiß nicht, ob man das hier sehen kann schon.
Genau.
Das da.
Das dürft ihr auf keinen Fall machen.
Kostenlose Gravur erstellen.
Weil wenn euch das Tablet,
das, das wirkt jetzt erstmal so,
als ist Apple übelst, übelst gönnerhaft.
Ja.
So nach dem Motto,
was kostenlose Gravur?
Uh, nice.
Poggers, Alter.
Das Problem ist aber,
wenn ihr eine kostenlose Gravur erstellt
und euch das Tablet nicht gefällt,
könnt ihr es nicht zurückgeben.
Das ist natürlich doof.
Super grobi,
wenn du schon fünf eingeschickt hast,
dann reicht das.
Das ist quasi,
das ist der übelste Debate von Apple.
Kostenlose Gravur hinzufügen
und damit gibst du gleichzeitig auf,
dass du den Kram wieder zurückgeben kannst.
Und das ist ja dann quasi
individuell für dich angefertigt.
Das muss man glaube ich auch irgendwie,
wenn man erstellen anklickt.
Poggers Stream.
Ich glaube, das kriegt man auch irgendwo angezeigt,
dass man das da nicht mehr,
dass man das da nicht mehr zurückgeben kann.
Chatter online.
Was passiert denn da?
Oh.
Die Bilder haben nicht das richtige Seitenverhältnis.
Ich weiß nicht, was da mit Apple los ist.
Naja, zumindest habe ich mir ein iPad bestellt jetzt.
Genug.
Aber das ist schon,
das ist schon harter Debate, oder?
Beast Mode.
Over 9000 abonniert.
Fünf Monate.
Huge Sub.
Huge Brain.
Mich würde ja mal interessieren,
wie die Abozahlen der großen Channels ausgesehen haben
vor Twitch Prime.
Mit Twitch Prime ist das bestimmt komplett explodiert.
Weil man sieht es ja,
also ich selber,
ich mache ja,
bis auf ganz wenige Ausnahmen,
mache ich nur Twitch Prime Abos.
So Leute,
wir gucken uns jetzt mal
ein übelstes Cringe Video an.
So, das ist so eine typische,
öffentlich-rechtliche Produktion.
Ich weiß gar nicht,
warum das so gute Bewertungen hat.
Und sie haben sich gedacht,
sie fragen mal Leute,
die in der IT arbeiten,
warum sie keine Freundin haben
oder ob das wahr ist,
dass sie keine Freundin haben,
ob die ganzen Vorurteile stimmen.
Ich habe mir das Video vorher schon angeguckt.
Das ist,
das ist,
es ist wirklich hart,
hart,
es ist schwer,
schwer zu ertragen.
Und was ich,
was ich witzig finde,
dass von den ganzen Leuten hier
gefühlt irgendwie,
weiß nicht,
die machen alle nicht den Eindruck,
als sind sie so die richtigen,
großartigen ITler.
Ich weiß nicht,
gucken wir mal,
ob wir das laut genug kriegen.
Das ist die Frage,
mit der jeder gerechnet hat.
Einfache Frage,
einfache Antwort.
Guck mal,
allein schon,
dass da Grills dabei sind,
ist schon mal absolut nicht
der Realität entsprechend.
Und dann auch noch hübsche Grills.
Das ist in Kombination,
ist das ja überhaupt nicht,
überhaupt,
kommt überhaupt nicht vor.
Wobei,
das kann man so,
das kann man mittlerweile
echt nicht mehr sagen.
Muss ich an der Stelle
auch nochmal loswerden.
Das kann man an der Stelle
wirklich nicht mehr sagen.
Auf der Arbeit haben wir
auch immer mehr Mädels in der IT,
was ich prinzipiell echt gut finde.
Ich bin ja,
ich bin ja immer dafür,
dass man sagen sollte,
Leute macht, was ihr wollt.
Man muss,
man muss das den Leuten nicht,
nicht auf,
aufzwängen,
wenn sie nicht wollen.
Aber wenn das jemand machen will,
bin ich der Erste,
bin ich der Letzte,
der irgendwas denkt,
der das nicht will.
Und bei uns auf der Arbeit
werden es auch immer mehr.
Was aber witzig ist,
wenn man sich die Verteilung anguckt,
zum Beispiel,
das muss,
das muss ich jetzt mal,
muss ich jetzt mal,
muss ich jetzt mal zeigen.
So,
wenn man,
wenn man sich jetzt mal
den Konferenz Channel anguckt,
von,
von irgend so einer komischen,
von irgend so einer Konferenzseite,
ist ja erstmal egal.
Was ich cool finde,
erstens,
mittlerweile gibt es
auch mehr Talks von Frauen.
Das finde ich prinzipiell
gut.
Aber was ich witzig finde,
ist,
wie das Ganze verteilt ist.
Also,
wenn man hier mal durchscrollt,
also,
worauf ich raus will,
warte mal.
Ah,
Mr.
Hustors,
hier,
Leute,
Achtung,
ansteckend.
Was ich lustig finde,
bei der Verteilung ist,
genau,
was ich sagen wollte,
worauf ich raus will,
ist,
dass ja,
so immer die Diskussion läuft,
so nach dem Motto,
Frauen und Männer
haben unterschiedliche Interessen
und das können die einen gut,
das können die anderen gut
und sowas.
Und dann gibt es ja die,
die sagen so nach dem Motto,
nee,
stimmt nicht,
das können alle alles gleich gut
oder klar,
jeder,
jeder hat so seine Stärken.
Und was ich witzig finde,
wenn man sich die,
die Konferenztalks anguckt,
oder was ich finde,
was man da richtig gut raus erkennt,
ist,
dass Vorträge von Männern
sich zu 90 Prozent
wirklich um,
um so die harte Technik drehen
und so ein guter,
ein guter,
also ein großer Prozentsatz,
der Vorträge von Frauen
dreht sich zum Beispiel darum,
wie schaffe ich eine gute Atmosphäre
in meinem Team
und sowas in der Richtung.
Das sind Themen,
die sind nicht unwichtig.
Aber ich finde schon,
dass man anhand der Konferenztalkthemen
sieht,
dass die Interessen
schon ein bisschen
unterschiedlich verteilt sind.
Zugucker,
Twitch Prime,
sieben Monate abonniert er schon.
Moin.
Schon mal von Following at Home gelesen.
Klar,
das gibt es ja schon ewig,
gibt es ja schon ewig.
Da muss ich dir ganz ehrlich sagen,
Following at Home ist mir ziemlich,
juckt mich nicht,
kostet nur Strom und CPU.
Wenn man jetzt mal hier
die Videos durchguckt,
das muss ich euch jetzt mal kurz,
dass ich das jetzt auch nochmal
untermauern kann,
was ich,
was ich eigentlich sagen wollte.
Das Dumme ist,
man kann,
kann ich das nicht so einstellen,
dass ich die Videos untereinander sehe
und den kompletten Titel?
Weil auf der Android,
auf der,
auf der iOS App
kann ich das nicht irgendwie
so untereinander machen?
Weil hinten steht der Name
des Vortragenden.
Kann man das nicht irgendwie
in einem Grid,
in einem Grid einblenden
oder so?
So vielleicht?
Nee.
Wie kriege ich denn den Grid,
ich will den kompletten
Videotitel sehen,
Alter.
Wir machen jetzt Trick 17.
Mobile Punkt,
oh,
fuck.
Mobile.
Ach nee,
M,
M ist es nur,
M.
Ah,
jetzt macht er mich,
Mobile.
Ah,
ja,
zumindest,
man sieht's jetzt kacke,
ich kann es leider,
ich könnte,
ich könnte hier,
ich könnte mal das probieren.
Wie sieht das Ganze
auf dem iPhone,
nee,
ach,
leck mich doch,
YouTube,
mein Gott,
macht das kompliziert.
Zumindest,
wenn man sich das hier ausguckt.
Das ist ein Typ,
das ist ein Typ.
Das ist ein Typ.
Das ist auch ein Typ.
So,
und,
genau,
ist ein vortrag von einer frau also sprich das ist schon kein komplett hardcore technik thema
sondern das ist hier irgendwas mit mit user mit user interaktion das ist ein typ das ist
ein typ das ist keine ahnung das ist ein typ irgendwas to factor authentifizieren okay dass
das geht auch als technik durch man kann man sieht es jetzt man sieht jetzt echt kacke da
gibt es hier irgendwelche ki geschichten ui design ist dann von mädels und so was ich finde schon dass
man anhand der konferenz talks erkennt dass die leute eben und das ist ja auch nicht schlimm
irgendwie unterschiedliche interessen haben also sprich 90 prozent der männer konferenz talks ist
halt irgendwie technik rahmen und ein großer prozentsatz der der konferenz talks von frauen
geht um irgendwelche team building geschichten user experience interface design oder irgendwelche
anderen sachen ich bin es ich finde es prinzipiell gut
dass es auf konferenzen mittlerweile mehr weibliche speaker gibt allerdings gab er
letztens diese was war das in der konferenz in deutschland wo dann männer abgesagt haben
die konferenz wo dann der an veranstalter die konferenz absagen musste wo männer die
konferenz also wo männliche speaker gesagt haben sie wollen nicht an der konferenz teilnehmen weil
zu wenig frauen spieken und so also manchmal manchmal nimmst ein bisschen groteske züge
an das ganze
das ist weiß nicht das ist ein thema die uns mit leute ein bisschen ein bisschen am rad drehen
aktuell also die wir gucken müssen uns jetzt den ganzen tag vor dem rechner natürlich ein
bisschen bisschen leise ist ja auch nach feierabend auch noch der typ der tut ich habe
das video schon gesehen der typ das ist der einzige eintücher im ganzen video ich sag's
euch. Ihr müsst
euch mal die Antworten von ihm anhören und von den
anderen. Das ist der Einzige, der weiß,
wovon er spricht.
Wir stehen auch einen Großteil am Kickertisch
oder Tischtennisplatte. Zuhause
eigentlich gar nicht mehr.
Kickertisch. Ich kenne
wenige. Ich weiß, dass viele
Firmen Kickertische und Billardtische
hinstellen. Ich kenne
aber keinen richtigen Hardcore-ITler,
der gerne Billard oder Kicker spielt.
Hauptaufgaben
vor dem Rechner zu sitzen. Kaffeemaschine.
Kaffeemaschine. Toilette. Toilette.
Kicker. Kicker. Tischtennisplatte.
Kicker weder.
Kicker. Das ist so...
Das tut so weh, wenn ich mir das anhören muss.
Ihr hattet noch nie einen Freund
Freundin. Ihr hattet noch nie eine...
Echte Kellerkinder haben keine Freunde.
Generell kein Kontakt zu anderen Menschen.
Wie soll das funktionieren? Freundin, einen
Freund. Ich spreche aus Erfahrung.
Es ist nicht so, dass ich die anderen Leute schlecht machen will.
Ich glaube, die meisten
hatten wohl schon mal eine. Ich hatte schon mal
eine Freundin. Ich habe ein Kind mit meiner Freundin.
Ich hasse Kontakt zu anderen Menschen.
So muss das sein.
Das stimmt
auch nicht. Selbst wenn man Alexa
und Siri ausschließen möchte...
Das fängt mal ein guter Witz an.
Stimmt die Aussage natürlich nicht.
Ich bin gerade glücklich mit
mir. Oft ist es ja immer echt so ein
Vorurteil, dass so ITler oder
Nerds halt immer auf ewig
alleine sind. Kann man hier meine Nummer irgendwo
einblenden?
Ich dachte ja, sagt euch Leute, da ist dann
drüben recht. Das ist der einzige echte
ITler im ganzen Spot.
In der Schule seid ihr immer
die Außenseiter gewesen. Ja.
Und danach auch noch.
Kann ich persönlich jetzt wohl nicht bestätigen. Ich sagte doch, das ist der
einzige echte. Muss ich jetzt mal auch so behaupten,
hab ich jetzt... Wahrscheinlich, wenn
dort, wenn dort in
bei 1Live irgendwas kaputt ist,
rennen die anderen im Kreis und
machen die Hände hoch. Oh, es ist kaputt.
Und der andere geht hin. Krasser
Hexermann. Gefixt.
Ich kann mir das so richtig vorstellen.
Einzige Ahnung hat.
Für mich nicht so wahrgenommen unbedingt.
Also bei mir würde ich das jetzt auch nicht sagen. Wir hatten
immer so eine Clique. Aber jetzt rotten sich halt
diese Außenseiter zusammen. Insofern ist das nicht
ganz so schlimm. Jetzt sind wir die
Außenseiter. In eurem Beruf gibt
es noch Männer? Nein.
Aber 90%. Ich bin auch da.
Nicht nur, aber
fast. Ja, die gibt es, die Frauen,
aber in Unterzahl. Wobei
sich das, glaube ich, ein bisschen
in die Gegenrichtung entwickelt.
In Layern unter mir jetzt.
Sind wieder mehr Frauen am Start. Das finde ich
sehr gut. Ich öffne mal schnell
den Internet Explorer, okay?
Ich glaube doch, das ist ein Widerspruch in sich.
Geben wir mal schnell Internet Explorer.
Wenn sie lustig sein wollen.
Nicht unbedingt, wenn es nicht sein muss.
Eigentlich ist sie auch tot, ne?
Hat Microsoft aufgeregt. Siehste? Ist der Einzige,
der Ahnung hat. Es ist der Einzige,
der Ahnung hat von allen, die da sitzen.
Gibt es halt nicht mehr insofern.
Das war, glaube ich, der Satz, den man
gar nicht gerne hört als Mathematiker.
Da haben wir unseren Satz, den wir nicht hören möchten.
Eigentlich, ja. Ihr seht nie das Sonnenlicht.
Wozu auch?
Ja, richtig.
Und ich habe immer Sonnenlicht
im Gesicht. Ich glaube, das ist wirklich
so ein Klischee, dass echt die ganzen
IT-Leute nur
Rollos komplett runter. Und die Sonnenlicht ist auch nicht
so gut für den Bildschirm.
Es gibt diese Headlights.
Das stimmt.
Deswegen lässt man ja auch nicht
die
Sonne direkt auf dem Bildschirm scheinen,
sondern macht Licht im Büro an.
Der hat Ahnung.
Der hat Ahnung der Rechte. Alle anderen kannst du vergessen.
Man lässt uns aber zu groß.
Der ist ehrlich der Rechte, genau.
Welcher Satz nervt euch in eurem Job am meisten?
Oh.
Ich habe doch, ich weiß was.
Der Chat muss aber mitmachen,
was euch am meisten nervt. Also was mich
am meisten nervt ist, wenn mich
einer fragt,
wie lang dauert das?
Das geht mir am meisten so.
Kannst du ungefähr abschätzen,
wie lang das dauert?
Das geht mir am meisten auf den Keks.
Wenn, wenn, wenn, wenn, wenn ich irgendwie
einer fragt, so nach dem Motto, ja und,
das und das und das, können wir das machen?
Und du sagst dann, ja,
muss ich mal gucken, wie man das
am besten umsetzen könnte, was es dazu
gibt. Ich habe mich damit jetzt noch nicht
beschäftigt, aber, also prinzipiell
müsste das gehen, aber ich muss erst mal gucken.
Und die nächste Frage ist dann, ja, was meinst du, wie lang es dauert?
Oh, das Stream lag, kann das sein?
Laggt das Stream, Leute?
Hat das Stream gelaggt?
Oh!
Das Stream laggt.
Unity Media.
Äh, äh, Vodafone.
Vodafone.
Wartet mal.
Ich brauche,
ich brauche ein Vodafone-Logo.
Ich brauche ein Vodafone-Logo und dabei
machen wir dann einen, einen Kackhaufen-Emoji.
Ähm,
naja.
Copy Image. Wir machen das natürlich mit Paint,
so wie sich das gehört. Paint.
So, Paint.
Äh, und jetzt brauchen wir
ein, ein, ein, äh, äh,
was ist das? Poop-Emoji.
Den brauchen wir.
Perfekt. Gibt es den auch irgendwie in groß?
Apple, Apple-Style.
Apple-Style.
Sehr gut.
So, Copy Image.
Ah, yes.
Excellent.
Also, natürlich macht man sowas mit Paint,
mit was auch sonst, ne?
Ähm, dann kopieren wir das Ganze auf dem Desktop
als Vodafone und speichern das bei mir.
So, das brauche ich nämlich immer,
für den Fall der Fälle, dass es wieder ruckelt.
Ah, yes. Excellent.
Funktioniert. Sehr schön.
So, gucken wir mal weiter.
PaintChamp.
Haha.
PaintChamp ist ein super geiler Emote-Name.
Das muss ich mir aufschreiben.
PaintChamp.
Das gibt's bestimmt schon.
Das ist ein richtig...
Den Emo...
Das ist ein mega geiler Emote-Name.
PaintChamp.
Das ist dann...
PaintChamp, da machen wir den hier.
Der kriegt dann bloß irgendwie so ne...
Der braucht irgendwie so ne Bob Ross-Palette oder sowas.
Irgendwas dabei.
Das ist ne richtig gute Emote-Idee.
Okay, also, was nervt euch an eurem Job am meisten?
Wie gesagt, wenn mich einer fragt, wann was veröffentlicht wird,
fertig ist.
Max, das muss an deiner WPA-Benennung liegen.
Haha, ja.
Also, für alle, die es nicht mitgekriegt haben,
ich hab ja mit nem Vodafone-Techniker,
oder Unity Media Vodafone-Techniker telefoniert,
und der hat gesagt,
dass meine Verbindungsprobleme,
die ich hier hab und zu habe,
die, wohlgemerkt, mein Rechner ist nicht per WLAN dran,
die liegen daran,
dass meine WLAN-SSIDs
für 2,4 GHz und 5 GHz
die gleichen Namen verwenden.
Kannst du das auch sagen?
Kannst du mal kurz klauen?
Hä? Das ist echt Big Brain.
Das ist einer gleichen SSID.
So, also, was nervt am meisten?
Müssen wir uns jetzt noch angucken.
Wie gesagt, die Frage, wie lang es dauert,
geht mir am meisten auf den Keks.
Ist das schon fertig?
Du bist der Software-Entwickler, kannst du mir mal helfen?
Warum funktioniert das nicht?
Wisst ihr, ist der Einzige, der programmieren kann,
unser Dude hier drüben,
der Einzige, der programmieren kann, der Einzige, der Ahnung hat,
der Rest sitzt einfach nur da, hat keinen Plan.
Kannst du mir mal helfen?
Warum funktioniert das nicht?
Es gab halt so eine Zeit,
wo ich dann öfter mal Anrufe bekommen habe
von meinem Opa oder E-Mails oder Nachrichten,
dass ich doch mal bitte vorbeikommen soll,
weil ich ein Blatt ausdrucken soll für ihn.
Geschichten aus dem Paulanergarten.
Das dauert so lange.
Oh, meine Drucke funktioniert nicht.
Warum geht das nicht einfach?
Kalt man sich irgend so einen Entwickler schön am Nacken
und dann kannst du mal Leben machen.
Dann sagst du natürlich immer, immer gerne,
ja, have you tried turning it off and on again?
Yes, I did.
Naja, es hilft erstaunlich oft, ja.
Problemlösung Nummer eins auf jeden Fall.
Ja, also teilweise hilft es wirklich.
Und wenn das nicht funktioniert, ist man in der Regel erstmal gearscht.
Da muss man nämlich nachdenken.
Ja, und das ist schlimm.
Oftmals hilft es tatsächlich.
Ich habe irgendwie den Eindruck, außer dem einen Typ, ne,
außer dem einen Typ ist da kein IT dabei
oder keiner, der Ahnung hat.
Der Rest tut einfach nur weh.
Max, warum habe ich nur vier E-Mails?
Das liegt daran, weil du kein Tier-One-Sub bist.
Ne, das liegt daran, dass ich immer noch nicht auf Fiverr war
und mal irgendwelche Inder damit beauftragt haben,
mir Emotes zu malen.
Ne, Moment, Inder waren die, die...
Nein, Schwachsinn.
Inder waren die, die ich habe programmieren lassen,
auf Fiverr, wo nichts rausgekommen ist.
Emote-Designer, wahrscheinlich sind das keine Inder.
Da muss ich gucken.
Ich weiß, ich will da schon seit einem halben Jahr gucken.
Nikurok, acht Monate.
Oh, huge sub.
Q steigt jetzt unermesslich heute wieder vom Chat.
Stimmt.
Äh, Schickl, das geht auch.
Wenn Neustarten nicht geht, einfach mal in Connector blasen.
Das funktioniert auch.
Connector blasen ist generell immer eine super Geschichte.
Würdest du eine Powerline empfehlen?
Nö.
Stört mich eher.
Wenn ich meinen Drucker starte, schmiert mein Router ab.
Hat jemand eine Idee, was man machen kann?
Was?
Wie soll das denn bitte schön zusammenhängen?
Das ist G-Bait, das glaube ich dir nicht.
Warum sollte ein Drucker abschmieren, wenn du deinen Router startest?
Ach, nee, umgedreht.
Ah, ah, ah, ähm.
Ach, dein Router schmiert ab, wenn du deinen Drucker startest.
Das sollte aber auch nicht sein.
Das ist auch sehr merkwürdig.
Das klingt aber auch sehr merkwürdig.
Ist das irgendein billig TP-Link-Router oder so?
Das liegt daran, dass du Router sagst und nicht Router.
Die richtig coolen Leute sagen,
Router.
Die nächste Frage ist ja,
wenn Cisco-Leute Router sagen,
ist es Cisco oder ist es, wie manche Leute sagen,
Cisco?
Ich finde, Cisco ist wahnsinnig.
Tut weh.
Ich habe keine Ahnung.
Ich habe keine Ahnung,
warum dein Router abkackt,
wenn du deinen Drucker einschaltest.
Ist da Drucker per Kabel oder per WLAN dran?
Wobei, was sagt man?
Cisco?
Könnte man auch, könnte man auch Cisco machen oder sowas?
Ein Drucker macht einen Broadcast-Sturm.
Hast du das aus der Berufsschule, oder?
Warum sollte das ein Drucker machen?
Ist WLAN.
Hm.
Du könntest mal, äh, gehst du direkt über das WLAN von deinem Router
oder hast du noch einen Access-Point dran?
Das könntest du nämlich noch mal probieren.
Ansonsten habe ich ehrlich gesagt keine Ahnung.
Du könntest mal eine feste, eine feste DHCP-Reservierung
machen.
Für deinen Drucker, was natürlich bescheuert ist,
aber merkwürdig, man weiß ja nie, man muss alles durchprobieren.
Und du könntest deinem Drucker mal eine feste IP geben.
Ich würde einfach ein paar verschiedene Kombinationen
durchprobieren.
Es hat zwar alles logisch gesehen, ja, hat das alles
miteinander nichts zu tun.
Aber da muss ja eindeutig irgendwas kaputt sein,
weil ansonsten bringt ein Druckerstart den Router nicht
zum, zum Absturz.
Dann habe ich echt keine Ahnung.
Firmware-Update.
Hast du schon die neue Cloud-Key-Firmware?
Ich habe gar kein Cloud-Key.
Ich habe, ich habe mein Unify-Controller auf dem Raspberry Pi installiert.
Der updatet sich einfach von alleine.
Gut ist, also wahrscheinlich habe ich schon die neue, ja.
Ja, aber es kann nicht sein, dass ein WLAN-Drucker
einen Router zum Crashen bringt.
Also das ist auf erstens, Alter, ich habe irgendwas im Hals.
Das ist natürlich ein Fehler vom Router, vom Drucker,
wenn er so komische Dinger macht, die den Drucker zum Absturz,
den Router zum Absturz bringen.
Aber es ist auch definitiv ein Fehler in der Router-Firmware,
wenn ihn ein, ein kaputter Drucker zum Absturz bringen kann.
Leute, wir gucken mal, wollen wir ein bisschen Battlefield gucken?
Wir gucken mal ein bisschen Battlefield.
So als Einstimmung, dass ich heute vielleicht Bock drauf kriege,
mal ein Battlefield-Video zu machen.
Vielleicht ist das ein China-Router, ja, das kann natürlich sein.
Lautstärke ist gut, denke ich, ne?
Alter, die Gegner, was zum Teufel ist mit diesen Gegnern?
Das, das, glaube ich, das muss gestellt sein.
So, so bescheuert können die Gegner nicht sein.
Was hältst du von Mesh-WLAN? Sinnvolle Geschichte.
So, also, warte mal.
Nee, nee, nee.
So, so blöd, so blöd können die Gegner nicht sein.
Das, das ist...
Alter, das ist ja geil.
Ey, mehr Kokona geht nicht.
Guckt, wow.
Leute, mehr, das ist, das ist...
Das ist das Most-Kokona-Haus, was ich gesehen habe.
Guckt euch das mal an.
Fuck yeah.
We need guns.
Das ist...
Mehr geht nicht, mehr geht nicht, ey.
Alexa, we need lots of guns.
Huge Kokona.
Das Schlimme ist ja, wenn man Battlefield und Call of Duty gespielt hat,
kann man die, erkennt man die meisten Dinger sogar irgendwie, ne?
Ohne, dass ich die Namen jetzt zusammenkriege.
Aber was hat er, was hat er denn da hängen?
Das könnte eine TAR, das könnte eine TAR sein, oder?
Ich kenne ja die, ich kenne ja die Waffen nur aus dem Ding.
Das Ding habe ich auch schon in irgendeinem Game gesehen.
Ist da unten irgendeine Shotgun oder so?
Die kenne ich nicht genau.
Holst du dir das neue Doom, ja.
Aber das ist, das ist so krass, Kokona, dieses...
Ich finde das so geil, vor allem, wie sie sich kaputtlachen dabei noch.
Alexa, we need guns.
So geil, Alter, die Amis.
Das ist geil, Alter.
Na gut, okay, weiter, weiter, Battlefield.
Moment, ich muss noch ein bisschen...
Ich muss noch ein bisschen...
Moment.
Genau, also die Gegner, die sind so, die sind so hirnlos gerade.
Ähm, das, das, das glaube ich gar nicht, dass man so dumm sein kann, ne.
Guckt euch das mal an, die...
Der steht da, sniped, sniped voll in die Gegner rein.
Und die Gegner checken nix.
Was ist denn...
Und der Typ, der guckt ihn genau an.
Was ist denn mit denen los?
Sind die, sind, sind die komplett braindead, oder was?
Die Gegner.
Ja.
Triffen tut er auch nix, ja.
Übrigens wir haben für Leute, die nix treffen, wir haben nen extra Emote dafür.
Guckt mal hier.
Pega-Aim haben wir als Emote.
Falls ihr es noch nicht gesehen habt.
Was?
Das war doch kein Topplay.
Ernsthaft, das war doch kein Topplay.
Er schießt...
Er trifft, er trifft in die Menge von 50 Leuten irgendwie welche.
Und danach trifft er nix mehr.
Ja, und die Gegner sind einfach nur unglaublich dumm.
Ich meine, das war ein cooler, das war wieder ganz nice, aber trotzdem.
Dann stirbt er. Das war doch kein Topplay.
Das war Pepega-Play.
Ach, das war ein Quad Collateral?
Ist euch das aufgefallen, dass das ein Quad Collateral war?
Mir ist das überhaupt nicht aufgefallen.
Oi!
Wartet mal, das müssen wir uns mal gucken.
Quad Collateral, das kann man gar nicht richtig aussprechen.
Das war kein Quad Collateral.
Das auch nicht.
Das!
Das war der Quad Collateral.
Naja gut, aber mit 30...
Naja, ja gut, das ist cool, aber das war eher Glück, dass das funktioniert hat.
Ah, ne, ne, ne.
Ja, aber wo ist die Kunst glücklich?
Flank und einmal in die Menge.
Ja, verstehe ich auch nicht.
Willkommen bei der Topplay von Battlefield 4.
Zu Beginn hatten wir einen Clip von Shaduga, der einen Quad Collateral auf Battlefield 4 abnimmt.
Das sieht man nicht so sehr.
Bam!
Die Pepega-Gegner, ey!
Fünf Leute insgesamt.
Wisst ihr, was mich ja so ein bisschen traurig macht bei Battlefield?
Richtig Pepehands, ja.
Wenn ich sehe, wie ich mich da schon reinsteigern kann,
wenn ich mich da schon reinsteigern kann,
jemanden nur zuzugucken, wenn er Battlefield 3 und 4 und sowas spielt,
wie toll ich das finde, rein beim Zugucken,
und wenn ich dann dran denke, ich müsste Battlefield 5 oder Battlefield 1 spielen,
und ich dann überhaupt keinen Bock mehr habe.
Das ist schon so ein bisschen Pepehands.
Das ist schon ein bisschen traurig,
dass man quasi von Videomaterial
so voll gehypt ist und denkt,
Alter, jetzt war eine Runde Battlefield und da fällt einem...
Nein, scheiße, das aktuelle Battlefield ist ja 5.
Und da hat man keinen Bock mehr.
Das ist schon doof, ne?
Die Map habe ich so selten gespielt.
Ich weiß gar nicht mehr, wie die heißt.
Das ist die Strand-Map.
Wie heißt das Ding nochmal?
Sag mal, wie groß hat denn der Kerl sein Interface?
Da siehst du ja gar nichts mehr.
Ja.
Okay.
Vor allem sind die Gegner aber wieder so doof und checken nicht, dass sie beschossen werden.
Ja.
all over Battlefield 4. They're pretty much on any rush map that you go on players' dice.
Look to make some additional cover for players. He is an attacker. He needs to get to the
objectives. He does exactly that as he smashes through the enemy.
Was ein bescheuertes Commentary. Er ist ein Angreifer. Er muss zum Objective. Und genau
das macht er. Er geht zum Objective. Alter, was ein Unterteil.
Gibt's auch ein Emote für gutes Aim? Habe ich noch keins gefunden.
Ich meine, er tappt die schon schön weg. Gegen das Play ist nichts zu sagen. Das ist
nice. Die Gegner checken halt immer wieder 0, dass sie beschossen werden.
Kennt ihr so die Gegner? Diese Gegner kennt jeder, ne? Du schießt, also gute Gegner merkst
du, wenn du die nicht schnell killst, dann drehen sie sich entweder um, checken sofort
wo du bist und schießen zurück. Oder machen halt irgendwelche Rumspringen.
Also, wenn du die nicht schnell killst, dann drehen sie sich entweder um, checken sofort wo du bist und schießen zurück. Oder machen halt irgendwelche Rumspringen.
Rumspringen, Cover, hinlegen, sonst was, Action. Und dann gibt's die
PPGA-Gegner, die beschossen werden und erst mal sich so umgucken und sagen
die Motto, von wo habe ich gerade Damage bekommen? Habe ich gerade Damage? Wo kam der
Damage her? Wo ist das? Oh, ich bin tot, Respawn.
Das sind so, das sind halt die richtigen PPGA-Gegner.
Na, tags. Habe ich das gesagt? Das trifft's ja auch richtig gut, ja.
Also, ich habe angeblich gesagt, zu den Battlefield 4 Spawns damals, es ist
ein Unterschied, ob jemand schlecht ist oder chancenlos vom Game verarscht wird.
Ich muss sagen, Max, das ist ein sehr gutes Zitat, ja. Da habe ich, da war
hier mal wieder Next Level IQ am Start, als ich mir das rausgedacht habe.
Jetzt, spontan komme ich auf so Sachen nicht. Da habe ich wahrscheinlich eine
Woche drüber nachgedacht, bis ich darauf gekommen bin.
Der tappt die schon krass weg, muss man mal sagen. Eine Runde locker. Ich habe das
Gefühl, die Hälfte der Clips sind locker.
Das gucken wir jetzt mal. Moment, welcher? Wo ist der Typ verlinkt?
Das da! sagt man ja? Was hat er so?Profess...Oh, rote,
rote Kreise! Leute, rote Kran...Oh guck mal, man kann da sich noch so richtig Wheels machen!
mit Battlefield Gameplay ist er. Den muss ich mir mal merken, vielleicht kann man sich von
dem auch ein paar Sachen angucken. Der macht ja richtig huge Fuse mit Battlefield 4, das ist ja
cool. Na gut, es gibt ja auch kaum noch Battlefield 4 Gameplays. Klingt wie
Sebaros zweite Couch. Ich glaube mal so gut ist das Sebaro in Battlefield nicht.
Was das für eine Waffe ist? ACR? Die ACR? Ja, ACR. Steht ja sogar da, ganz fett.
ACR habe ich auch, äh, ACR habe ich glaube ich 8% der Zeit in Battlefield 4 gespielt.
ACR beste. Der sprayt die aber ganz schön weg hier. Übrigens daran erkennt man auch,
Leute.
die wirklich die Map drin haben, ja, an dieser Aktion. Ich guck mal, ob man das jetzt sieht.
Hier ran. Jetzt gleich, der versucht, also man sieht, man sieht's jetzt, kommt jetzt,
kommt jetzt gleich. Der läuft, ich hoffe, ich hoffe, ich hab weit genug zurückgespielt. Der
rennt jetzt auf die Gegner zu, sieht, er kann grad nicht zurückschießen und ein Gegner kommt
um die Ecke und er geht quasi schon präventiv um die Ecke, weil er eben weiß, dass da eine Lücke
in der Map ist. Daran erkennt man auch, ob die Leute kapiert haben, wie das Game funktioniert,
beziehungsweise wie die Map aufgebaut ist. Dann guck mal, das hier meine ich jetzt. Ne,
ich hab nicht weit genug zurückgespielt. Oder? Ne, ich hab nicht weit genug zurückgespielt,
egal. Die checken es halt mal wieder gar nicht. Aber das ist ein ultra nicer Clip. Der basht
die aber mal richtig hart. Huge Streak, äh. Ah, ok, das, das war Pech. Das war, das war
jebaited, jebaited vom Battlefield, äh. Guck, der hat, der hat voll reingeballert und der,
klar im Endeffekt, okay, der Damage,
der Damage reicht, um
den zu killen. Ups, ne, doch
nicht registriert, die Hits. Und tot.
Zwar Pech.
Oh, nice.
Hab ich, glaub ich, nie
gespielt.
Ich finde, man, in den alten Battlefield
Teilen, also sagen wir so, bis Battlefield 4 hat man
immer noch dran erkannt, wie gut Gegner sind,
wie sie moven. Ich glaube, das ist in Battlefield
1 und 5 immer noch ähnlich, aber
gute Gegner sind in Battlefield 3
und 4 relativ schwierig zu treffen,
weil sie halt permanent moven und permanent
hinlegen, aufstehen,
Coverspringen, sonst was.
Und die Pepega-Gegner, die laufen einfach von A nach B.
Oh, cool.
Nice.
Der haut, oh, der,
what?
An, an, an was ist er gestorben
jetzt? Ich hab's nicht gecheckt.
An was, an was ist er gestorben?
Hä? Habt ihr's gecheckt, an was
er gestorben ist? Ich kapier's nicht.
What?
Der wurde weggesprayt von,
am Tor.
Jetzt hier rechts, oder was?
Ah!
Aber, das ist so ein typischer Battlefield,
ich hab's jetzt gesehen am Tor, das ist aber so ein typischer,
ähm,
so ein, so ein, was mit Punkt und Dings,
kann man Frames vorspulen, echt?
Boah, huge!
Das wusste ich ja noch gar nicht.
Guck mal hier, Leute.
Einzel Frames vorspulen auf YouTube,
was man nicht alles lernt, hier, Leute,
auf WTF, der Chat.
Alter, der Chat.
Wusste ich nicht, dass das geht.
Das muss ich mir, das muss ich mir gleich mal notieren.
Also, da, da,
Framespulen, YouTube.
Ich mein, man sieht hier ganz klar,
wer von uns hier der YouTuber ist,
und wer nur der Zuschauer.
Das ist ja cool.
Wollt ihr das mal?
Guck hier, da, der Typ hat ihn gekillt, da, hier.
Rechts, der, der da.
Der hier, der hat ihn gekillt.
Okay.
Einfach.
Ne, das kannte ich noch nicht.
Echt nicht.
Boah, der haut die aber krass weg, ey.
Und ich hab jetzt so Bock,
quasi, direkt Battlefield zu spielen,
und dann fällt mir ein,
fuck, ich müsste ja Battlefield 5 spielen.
Äh, 1, ne, 5, und da hab ich keinen Bock drauf.
Erstmal Farbenclip-Modus.
Hand.
Das war geil, oder?
Das war nice.
Da müsst ihr mal ein bisschen mehr ausflippen, der Kommentator.
Das war extrem pock.
Ja, Leute, guckt euch das mal an.
Der springt raus,
smort den Heli
und springt in seinen Jet wieder rein.
WTF.
Das ist übelst krass.
Das ist wahnsinnig nice.
Das ist übelst krass gewesen.
Das ist ohne Scheiß, Leute.
Irgendwie habe ich das Gefühl, das war es ja gar nicht zu wenig.
Das ist eines der geilsten Clips,
die ich je gesehen habe.
Der killt ein Flugzeug, springt raus,
er piggert einen Heli, springt in sein Flugzeug,
wieder reinkillt ein anderes Flugzeug.
Megakrass, ey.
Stuntman, sein Vater, genau.
Stuntman, sein toter Vater, vor allem,
wenn er das machen würde.
Und dann kommt er wieder rein.
Leute, ich weiß, dass du das prinzipiell in vielen Battlefields machen kannst.
Aber wo habt ihr so einen Clip in der Ausführung schon mal gesehen?
Dass du das seit Ewigkeiten machen kannst, ist ja das eine.
Aber dass Leute das machen, ist ja dann das ganz andere.
Und in der Ausführung habe ich den Clip noch nie gesehen.
Oder zumindest schon keinen, der mir im Kopf geblieben ist.
Das war ein übelst, übelst nice, wie er das gemacht hat.
Das ist vor allem so weich ineinander.
Klar, wir haben schon viele Clips gesehen, wo Leute rausgesprungen sind, getroffen haben.
Aber der hat gekillt, rausgesprungen, im Flug den anderen Heli gekillt, reingesprungen
und noch ein anderes Flugzeug gekillt.
Das so, in der Art und Weise habe ich so einen Clip noch nicht gesehen.
Ich weiß, ich kann mir jetzt vorstellen, wir haben jetzt ein paar Leute im Chat,
die jetzt quasi auf YouTube gehen und sagen,
so lange ich hier bin, habe ich keine Ahnung,
ich mache die Motto, Best Battlefield Plane Montage
und schicken mir dann in zwei Minuten den Clip und sagen,
Max, guck da, da gibt es noch einen besseren Clip.
Weil das kann ja nicht sein, ne?
Oh, da wäre jetzt weg, Shotgun.
Mann, was hat der für Soundsettings?
Die Badewannen-Soundsettings.
Das war typisch, am Ende war typisches Battlefield 4 Clusterfuck.
Du hast überhaupt nicht mehr durchgeblickt,
wo was abgeht.
G18 ist übelst nice, ja.
Warum macht das Ding übertrieben Damage, die G18?
Nur G18 Akimbo war noch besser.
MX4, ich glaube, das Ding habe ich nie gespielt.
Oh, weggesniped.
Obwohl, das war trotzdem nice, das Ding.
Oh, Metro.
Clusterfuck Metro.
Das ist der Spaz 12,
aber er geht auf den PKP
mit einem satisfernten Kitswitch
halbwegs durch.
Ein wirklich guter,
weil er für rund 30 Sekunden
die Enemieteam
auf Operation Metro dominiert.
Und passiert ja noch nichts.
Bam.
Oh ne, wurde ihm weggemessert, der Typ.
YouTube Lies, das habe ich ja schon öfters erklärt,
warum ich YouTube Lies dort mache.
Oh, der spielt Slug Ammo, oder?
Das ist ein 30 Kilometer Range.
Spray, spray, spray, spray.
Wisst ihr, was das Geile ist?
Wenn du dir das anguckst,
du hast direkt das Gefühl wieder,
dass das hier richtig geile Battlefield Action am Start ist.
Und dann denke ich mir so,
ja, aber Battlefield 4 jetzt noch anfangen
mit quasi nur noch leeren Servern,
will ich auch nicht.
Oder wieder anfangen.
Du konntest in dem Game so übertrieben
die Gegner wegsprayen.
Ach, das ist nicht Dawnbreaker?
Ich finde, es sieht aus wie Dawnbreaker,
die Map.
Das ist aber anscheinend nicht Dawnbreaker.
Oh, die Gegner.
Oh Gott.
Das tut ja schon weh beim Zugucken.
Der spielt nicht einfach 4 zu 3, oder?
Spielt der 4 zu 3?
Wahrscheinlich auch noch auf dem Röhrenmonitor oder so.
Solche Gegner gibt es einfach nicht mehr.
Die Clips sind wohl aktuell.
Man müsste...
Alter, was ist das für eine Quali?
Der Stiefelstiefel.
Ich wusste noch gar nicht,
dass es ein Wii-Port,
ein Gamecube-Port gab von Battlefield 4.
Guck mal, du kannst...
Guckt euch das mal an.
Moment, Leute, wartet mal.
Lupe, guckt mal.
Guckt mal.
Das ist der Gegner da vorne.
Hahaha.
Excellent.
Oh, fuck.
Wie kriege ich den Kram wieder aus?
Excellent Sicht, Alter.
Ups.
Ah, Fullscreen.
Nur ein Pixel-Headshot.
Bestimmt CS-Pro.
Die spielen auch sowas, ja.
Ich habe letztens mal eine Tabelle gesehen von CS-Pros.
Und da gibt es sogar viele mittlerweile,
die auf ordentliche Auflösungen angekommen sind, ja.
Es gibt sogar ein paar CS-Pros,
ein paar ganz wenige,
die tatsächlich 1920x1080 spielen.
Aber die 800x600-Ära ist wohl endgültig vorbei.
Once again using the AEK,
the second one is going to be an aggressive push
onto Charlie Objective.
This is how you do it when the enemy...
Has the crap quality, Alter.
...can't seem to get through.
Rush through, couple of grenades,
spot whoever is trying to block and hold the doorway,
take them down.
Und luckily for him...
Ich meine, was hat denn der für einen Rechner,
wenn er so eine Auflösung spielt?
Das ist ja ein sehr guter Rechner.
...wenn er so eine Auflösung spielen muss
und dann auf low details...
Ich meine, bashen tut er das schon hart.
Wegklatschen tut er das schon echt gut hier.
Ah, die Waffe ist auch nice.
Nochmal.
Locker.
Und keinerlei Anti-Aliasing.
Guckt euch mal die Kanten an.
Ich frage mich, wie der Typ abgehen würde,
wenn er die Gegner auch erkennen würde.
Ha!
Sag mal, wie unfähig kann man als Gegner eigentlich sein?
Guckt mal, die stehen zu zweit in der Ecke.
Der Typ ist angehittet von der Claymore
und die schaffen es zu zweit nicht,
oder sie schaffen es nicht, ordentlich ihn zu killen.
Oh, ein Gegner.
Ja, wo kommt der denn her?
Ach, lass erstmal hier weiter in der Ecke stehen
und nix machen.
Und dann killen sie ihn ja auch nur
mit einem abgeprallten Noob-Tube.
Oh, jetzt wird Heli gesniped.
Okay.
Okay, Leute.
Sind das aktuelle Clips?
Angeblich schon.
Das war Glück.
Leute, das war Glück.
Guckt euch das mal an, das war Glück.
Hallo, ich will vorspulen, YouTube.
Das ist Glück.
Das ist mega Glück.
Da kann mir keiner erzählen, dass das predicted war.
Im Leben nicht.
Im Leben nicht war das predicted.
Seid erstmal Quickmuffs gemacht vorher.
Im Leben nicht.
Im Leben nicht war das predicted.
Nochmal, nochmal.
Und der zweite Clip, den er mitgebracht hat, ist ziemlich lustig.
Er hat sich von einem Admin getötet,
weil er mit dem Sniper getötet hat,
weil sie einen unbegrenzten Sniper-Slot hatten.
Das war ziemlich cool,
weil er weiß, dass der Pilot-Streit nicht gescopet ist.
Hehehehe.
Sniper-Limit.
Übrigens, eines der besten Erfindungen
für Battlefield-Server aller Zeiten.
Sniper-Limit.
Sie haben es ja schon in Battlefield 4 ein bisschen abgeschwächt,
dass man das gar nicht beim Spawn richtig implementieren kann.
Ähm, aber gerade auf Rush-Maps war das,
essentiell, ähm,
man hat ja in der, also in der Regel waren,
wenn die Runden gut waren,
hatte man jetzt auch nicht übertrieben viele defensiv
am, am Arsch der Welt rumliege Sniper.
Ähm, die Sache ist nur die,
wenn man konstant, äh,
schöne Runden haben wollte, war es wichtig,
dass man es verbietet,
dass 80% des Teams Sniper am Arsch der Welt sein können,
weil sonst geht nichts vorwärts.
Und da haben sie sich ja in Battlefield 1 und 5 gedacht,
nee, das geht ja nicht, dass Server-Admins den Leuten vorschreiben dürfen, dass sie
etwas nicht spielen dürfen, so geht's nicht.
Ich, äh, ich weiß gar nicht, wie es in Battlefield 5 ist.
Sie haben es, ähm, mit, ähm,
die Server-Software in Battlefield 4 hat es schon schwieriger gemacht,
oder was auch immer, am besten ging es in der Server-Software von Bad Company 2.
Da konntest du, glaube ich, direkt beim Spawn Sniper-Limit machen.
Battlefield 3, Battlefield 4 war es irgendwie so, dass du nicht auslesen konntest,
welche Klasse jemand spawnt, bis er etwas killt.
Ähm, es wurde immer restriktiver, was du machen konntest.
Du musst ja, wo quasi, ähm,
die, die Programmierer von Plugins mussten sich
richtig was einfallen lassen.
Und ehrlich gesagt weiß ich gar nicht, wie das in Battlefield 5 ist.
Gibt es in Battlefield 5 überhaupt noch eigene Server,
wo man, wo man auch, äh, Admin-Software hat mit, mit Plugins und sowas?
Gibt's das überhaupt noch?
Ich weiß, dass es jetzt Fallout 76 Server gibt, aber...
Das passt ja jetzt nicht wirklich dazu, ist mir nur gerade so eingefallen.
Und ich werde dich fangen.
So, den, den Typ speicher ich mir mal.
Den, den sub ich auch auf meinem, den sub ich auch mal.
Ähm, dass ich mir das merken kann.
Dass wir ein bisschen Battlefield, Battlefield-Gameplay haben zu gucken, wenn es gerade keine Top-Plays gibt.
Der Typ scheint ja echt nice zu sein hier.
So, was haben wir als nächstes für Video-Auswahl?
Was wollen wir gucken?
Also, irgendeiner, der einen Raspberry Pi 4 als Desktop-Ersatz betreiben will.
Ähm, dann, äh, äh, äh, First, First Look für das neue Windows 10X.
Wo ich mich immer noch frage, was hat Microsoft eigentlich genau vor?
So.
Äh, wir können uns den Bauer angucken, der wieder irgendwelche CPUs wahrscheinlich overclockt.
Dann haben wir Worst Maps in Call of Duty.
Dann haben wir den, den Lockpicking-Lawyer.
Mal wieder ein paar Videos von.
Ähm, da können wir uns Linus angucken mit einer 20 Dollar SSD.
Äh, da haben wir noch ein bisschen GameStar, noch ein bisschen Lockpicking.
Das Video ist cool, das wollte ich schon mal gucken.
Da hab ich die ersten 5 Minuten geguckt, das war echt interessant.
Der hat sich...
Das, das können wir...
Der hat sich nen, nen, nen Python-Skript programmiert, was alle Botschaften und, und, äh, ja, Botschaften auf der Welt anschreibt, ob sie eben nicht Flaggen schicken können.
Und die haben's gemacht.
Das gucken wir uns jetzt an, das war ein cooles Video.
This is the story of how I got almost half of the countries of the world to send me their flag for free.
I had a small flag collection, nothing impressive, just a handful of tiny flags, mostly a couple of souvenirs from a few different countries.
And I wanted to extend my collection.
And with 193 countries in the world, there was still a long way to go.
So, I considered a few different options for obtaining flags.
One would be to just go online, type flags, press some different ones, like this one...
Ja, das ist ja, das ist ja zu Noob-Style, einfach zu bestellen.
...this one and this one.
The problem is...
Ähm, äh, Assassin, du wirst gleich sehen, ein, von Hand ne Mail zu schreiben ist doof, wenn du irgendwie 800 Botschaften anschreiben willst oder so.
...send you the flag.
You're taken to a page where you're supposed to fill in some credit card details.
Fill in some credit card details and press enter.
After you do this, the amount of money goes missing from your bank account and you don't have it anymore.
Another option would be to text a friend...
Der, der, der Typ, der Typ hört sich übelst an, wie, wie...
Warte mal, wie, wie...
Der, der, der hört sich übelst bekannt an.
...ask if he wants to go somewhere, somehow get...
Der hört sich irgendwie an, wie nen, wie nen Däne, oder? Vom, vom Akzent her.
Irgendwie dänisch.
Wobei, ist, äh, der ist ja auch dänisch. WTF, sagt er ja auch im Video.
Aber der erinnert mich, der erinnert mich an irgendjemand.
An irgendeinen Streamer erinnert er mich, von, von, von der Stimme her.
Ne, der ist dänisch, das weiß ich, das sagt er auch im Video später.
Der erinnert mich an irgendeinen Streamer.
Was gibt's denn?
Äh, der Fran, natürlich!
Der McDonalds-Mann.
Genau, der ist auch Däne.
...pack your bag, go there, and get the flag.
The problem with this solution is...
Der hört sich übelst an, wie der Fran.
I live here...
...and while recording this video, it's winter in the northern half of the world, so a lot of countries are way too cold.
In some places they drive in the wrong side of the road, the food is too spicy in some countries, some are too French, some are too far away from where I live, some are too close.
That leaves a very small section of the world's countries I can go and collect flags from.
And it would probably also end up costing me money.
Of course, some flags you can draw by yourself, if you have a nice set of colorful pens.
Oh, huge drawing skills.
But most of them are just way too complicated.
So, clearly there's only one easy way to get flags.
Just ask every country directly for a flag.
I figured there were two ways to contact them.
Im Hintergrund die Fahrstuhl-Jazz-Musik.
Hast du von dem Folding at Home gehört, was Nvidia gepusht hat?
Nee.
Ich meine, Folding at Home an sich kenne ich.
Fand ich bis jetzt aber ziemlich, ähm...
Was ist daran jetzt neu und besser?
...their foreign representations, such as the embassies and consulates abroad.
A second is their internal governments, especially their ministries of foreign affairs, tourism and culture.
Well, to ask them I needed their emails.
Unfortunately I couldn't find a single list anywhere of all these emails, so I had to compile it myself.
I wanted to minimize my mental labor, so I wrote a Python script to help me collect these details.
When starting any coding project, you should of course start by setting the color scheme of your terminal and editor to some dark combination.
So you look like a cool hacker from a movie.
I found a page called EmbassyWorldWide.com, which had all the contact information about the worldwide...
Pling Project, you should of course start by setting the color scheme of your terminal and editor to some dark combination, so you look like a cool hacker from a movie.
So, so ist gut, so ist gut. So muss es machen .
... embassyworldwide.com, which had all the contact information about the worldwide...
Oh Leute, ich muss euch was fragen, bitte. Und zwar, ich bin gerade dabei, mit jemand anderem was zu... programmiert projktmäßig, was zu machen.
... und ich muss euch was fragen, bitte. Und zwar, ich bin gerade dabei, mit jemand anderem voulez... programmierprojektmäßig, was zu machen.
Wir brauchen einen ordentlichen Geocoding-Service, also Geocoding ist, wenn du quasi auflöst, Koordinaten zu Adresse oder Adresse zu Koordinaten und sowas, das sich auch dafür eignet, Autocomplete zu machen.
Also im Prinzip das, was Google anbietet, Google Places nennt sich das, Google Places ist das, was auch bei Google Maps drunter ist.
Wenn ich hier zum Beispiel eintippe, irgendwie Hauptbahnhof Frankfurt, dann funktioniert das, also sprich, eine API für Geocoding.
So, kennt da jemand was Gutes, was kostenlos ist? Ich meine, ich habe auch keine Schmerzen mit Google Maps zu machen, beziehungsweise Google Places, ein bisschen was zu bezahlen, das kostet ja nicht die Welt.
Ich habe mir sehr viele Lösungen angeguckt und die sind alle nicht annähernd so gut, wie Google Places.
Die einen haben keine Postleitzahlen drin, die anderen haben, wenn du nach BER suchst aus Deutschland, zeigen sie dir nicht Berlin an, sondern irgendeine Stadt in Uganda, die mit BER anfängt und sowas.
Die waren alle ziemlicher Crap.
Das Beste, was ich bisher gefunden habe, ist das hier von OpenStreetMaps.
Da kann man...
Da kann man zum Beispiel eingeben, Frankfurt Hauptbahnhof und dann findet er das.
Das funktioniert, aber dieser Service hat keine... also die kann man nicht verwenden, da kann man nur eine Abfrage pro Sekunde machen, das ist zu wenig.
Man kann ihn allerdings selbst hosten.
Man kann ihn allerdings selbst hosten und das ist das, was ich mir gerade überlegt habe.
Aber der Service ist nicht so gut wie Google Places.
Also aktuell wollte ich das hier machen, ja.
Aktuell wollte ich mir das selber hosten, einfach hier den Docker-Container da mit drin und dann die OpenStreetView-Daten importieren.
Aber lieber...
Ne, ne, ne, das muss nicht selbst gehostet sein.
Das muss nicht selbst gehostet sein.
Also am liebsten wäre mir ein Geo-Coding oder ein Geo-Service, der so gut ist wie Google Places.
Also sprich Google Places und Google Places Autocomplete, das ist das, was auch unter Google Maps drunter ist.
Also das ist das, was auch unter Google Maps drunter ist.
Ähm, aber kostenlos.
Okay, ich gebe zu, die Anforderung ist ein bisschen doof, ja.
Also wenn es gut sein soll und kostenlos ist halt...
Aber vielleicht kennt jemand was.
Vielleicht kennt jemand was Gutes.
Nein, die Anwendung wird nicht öffentlich gemacht, weil die haben wir schon verkauft.
Also hat auch keiner von euch eine Ahnung, oder?
Okay, wo sind wir stehen geblieben?
Ja.
Es scheint ein bisschen unkonsistent.
Zum Beispiel, wenn man Australien und Australien macht, aber sonst...
Das überrascht mich immer, dass das viele hinkriegen, ja.
Reicht das YouTube-Money jetzt nicht mehr?
Ähm, das YouTube-Money reicht schon ewig nicht mehr, weil ich nix mache auf YouTube.
Dafür gibt's jetzt ja Twitch-Money.
Das heißt, wenn euch der Stream gefällt und ihr noch einen kostenlosen Prime-Sub übrig habt,
dann wisst ihr ja, was ihr damit machen könnt.
Dann könnt ihr einen Streamer eurer Wahl kostenlos unterstützen mit einem Tier-One-Sub.
Unglaublich.
Satan Kitty's Twitch-Prime-Huge-Sub.
Dankeschön.
Und wisst ihr, was das Beste an einem Twitch-Prime-Sub ist?
Ihr bekommt alle Vorteile von einem normalen Sub, ohne dass es euch was kostet,
und ihr könnt einen Streamer eurer Wahl kostenlos unterstützen.
Genauso wie jeder andere Sub auch zählt es, obwohl es euch nichts kostet.
Daddel1905, Twitch-Prime, dankeschön.
Ich muss öfters sehr laut machen, das bringt einfach was.
Äh, Donaten hab ich ausgemacht.
Ähm, also du...
Man, man, man, man, man...
Konnte mal donaten, aber der Donation-Tracker war kaputt.
Und bevor ich das Risiko eingehe, dass, ähm...
Die Donations...
Dass ich die Donations nicht mitbekomme, hab ich den Donation-Tracker und den Donation-Link entfernt.
Solltest du öfters erwähnen?
Ja, ich weiß, ich weiß, ich...
Oh, der Hype-Train, Leute!
Der Scam-Train ist am Start.
Der Scam-Train läuft.
Der Bait-Train.
M... Mikaim.
Mikaim?
Ich bin mir nicht ganz sicher, wie man das ausspricht.
Aber dankeschön für vier Monate Twitch Prime.
Man kann auch gratis followen, das ist richtig.
Followen ist sogar noch mal eine Nummer mehr, Big Brain.
Followen ist schon Six Head, weil das kostet nix und es bringt euch auch nix.
Außer, dass ihr seht, wenn die Leute online gehen.
Das ist eigentlich...
Followen ist eigentlich das Beste, was man machen kann.
Hat keiner richtig was von.
Außer, dass man halt sieht, dass die Leute online gehen, ne?
Zibitz, fünf Monate, dankeschön.
Und...
Der, der, der Ch...
Hundert...
Leute, der Scam-Train.
Er fährt.
Warum hab ich davon eigentlich kein transparentes GIF?
Warum hab ich davon kein transparentes GIF?
Das sieht richtig fell, ne?
Das sieht gut aus und das sieht übelst reulich aus.
Kann man die über Paypal was schicken?
Ja, aber, wie gesagt, nee, nee, ich hab den Donation-Link rausgemacht, weil das Tracking nicht mehr funktioniert.
Okay, gucken wir weiter.
Ah, langer, die ganzen Subs.
Äh, wie bin ich jetzt eigentlich drauf gekommen?
Genau, also, wie gesagt, das YouTube-Modell.
Das YouTube-Modell.
Reicht schon Jahre nicht mehr, weil warum sollte das reichen?
Ich mach ja nix mehr auf YouTube.
Ähm, äh, soll ich jetzt dich oder die vollbusige LOL-Streamerin mit Primes haben?
Äh, ich würde sagen, du solltest einen Charity-Speedrun-Marathon suppen, der nicht GameStun-Quick ist.
Wen juckt das Tracking?
Mir geht keine ab, wenn jemand meinen Namen vorliest.
Aber ich seh's nicht.
Das ist ziemlich, äh, ziemlich kacke, ja?
Also, ich find's blöd, wenn Leute...
...denken und ich krieg es überhaupt nicht mit.
Weil ich guck ja auch nicht jeden Tag irgendwie in den PayPal-Account dafür rein.
So, wir gucken jetzt erstmal weiter.
Aber wie gesagt, danke für die ganzen...
...Samskrimer!
Hä!
Da hat er recht.
Were are we in the sea?
One for the host country and one for the email address.
Just because it's cooler to say I wrote to every country, I had to manually search and add about seven countries.
Marshall Islands, wo zum Teufel liegt das überhaupt?
Most is all island nations, which I did not have in my database.
I also throw in all the permanent missions to the UN, just for good luck.
Oh, and about 200 different ministries and government officials around the world while still trying to make sure I was not writing to the wrong people.
I quickly wrote a template for an email that went something like this.
In Marshall?
Ist Marshall nicht ein Lautsprecherhersteller?
Yeah.
In a country.
Na, wer kann da nicht widerstehen bei dieser Mail?
Ist Marshall Islands, ist das die, die, die, ja, das ist die Steuerhinterziehungs, ich dachte, das ist in Luxemburg.
Die Steuerhinterziehungsinsel.
Da ist was dran.
Ich finde ja cool, dass die da drauf reagieren, ne?
Togo?
Wo ist das überhaupt?
Wo ist Togo?
Irgendwo in Afrika, hä?
Togo.
Afrika.
Ah, yes, excellent.
Ach, da!
Ach, sagt es doch gleich, da ist das alles klar.
Ah, jetzt weiß ich Bescheid.
Jetzt weiß ich Bescheid.
Da ist das, natürlich, wusste ich, wusste ich vorher schon.
Ich finde es aber echt cool, dass die da drauf antworten.
Aber ich meine, gut, die müssen halt repräsentieren, das ist ihr Job.
Ob Togo besseres Internet hat als wir?
Ob die 50 MBit für jeden geschafft haben?
Boah!
Ich habe neue E-Mails.
Sie kommen schneller ein, als ich antworten konnte.
Boah!
Fast jeder war überrascht.
Ist das MLG?
MLG, die MLG Botschaft?
Ich war glücklich und unterstützend und habe meine Anforderungen sehr ernst genommen.
Ob die eine Gala-Optik-Brille aufhaben?
Wer sonst mir helfen könnte, hat mir Weihnachtsgeschenke gegeben und nur General Smalltalk.
Die Embassy von Iran auf der Inland-Route.
Es ist eine Leidenschaft, dass wir wegen der Sanktionen nichts zu nirgendwo senden konnten.
Du kannst mir nichts nicht senden.
Ja, das ist halt der Iran, da haben sie recht, ja.
Ja, das ist halt der Iran, da haben sie recht, ja. Sie können nichts nicht senden.
Sie können nirgendwo irgendwas irgendwo hinschicken.
Was wär?
Okay, es gibt keine Flagge, es gibt den dänischen Pin.
Auch gut.
Oh!
Oh, liegt Leute, liegt!
Habt ihr es gesehen? Habt ihr es gesehen?
Gut.
Liegt!
Sebastian Holdum.
Oh, das Recht kann ich nicht aussprechen, aber halt irgendwo in Kopenhagen.
Ich hab sowas ja auch schon geschafft, ne?
Ich hab ja meine alte Adresse auch schon geleakt auf nem DHL, DHL, äh, äh, Sticker.
Die Embassy in Kopenhagen wurde bald mit dieser Triangular Flagge folgt.
Die afghanische Embassy in Frankreich sendet diese kleine Letter.
Die österreichische Embassy sendet auch eine Flagge.
Es hat ein paar Tage gedauert, bis die Packungen wirklich angefangen haben.
Bangladesch war sehr kind und hat mir eine Flagge gegeben.
Sri Lanka sendet auch eine Flagge.
Es gab viele Duplikate, aber.
Finnland sendet eine Flagge, sowohl von der Embassy in Deutschland als auch von Belgien.
Slowenien mailte ein paar Flagge aus Griechenland.
Und diese hier aus Dänemark.
Ich habe ein E-Mail von dem Premierminister aus Schweden bekommen, der sagt,
leider können wir dir nicht helfen, deine Flagge zu sammeln.
Lass uns bitte wissen, ob du das Autograf von Premierminister Löwen möchtest.
Was?
Du schreibst da hin, weil du eine Frage hast.
Its 사실 geile.
Das ist eigentlich eine geile Taktik.
Das ist eine geile Taktik.
Oh, da fällt mir was ein, was wir mal auf der Arbeit hatten.
Eigentlich ist wir schon in der intense luggage gespielt worden.
Also wir machen ja da eigentlich auch eine Spitzenreise.
Denn wir müssen ja es nur so sehen, ob wir reise können.
So.
Whatever.
What do you mean?
Okay?
eigentlich ist das eine richtig, richtig geile
Taktik, ähm,
eine richtig geile Taktik,
so nach dem Motto, äh, Max, kannst du mir
mal das und das machen? Ähm, nee,
aber möchtest du ein Autogramm von mir?
Hahaha, was ne,
was ne, das ist die, das ist die
bescheuertste Antwort, die du jemandem geben
kannst, ey.
Ja, da fällt mir, da fällt
mir was zu ein, und zwar,
bei uns, auf der Arbeit, ist das so,
wenn Azubis am Start
sind, die müssen, das erste
halbe Jahr,
gehen die quasi, also,
Leute, hier, cool, cool,
cool Story, Bob, angesagt, ja,
ähm, also, die,
was zum Geier ist das?
Okay, ähm,
bei uns müssen die Azubis das erste halbe Jahr
quasi durch alle Abteilungen mal durch
und da eine Woche rumhocken, so,
und danach, und da hat keiner
der Azubis Bock drauf,
kann ich auch verstehen, ist auch total,
total für den Arsch, danach müssen die
quasi,
einmal im Monat, äh, vor einem
ausgewählten Führungskräftekreis
präsentieren, was sie gelernt haben.
Also, richtig, richtig, richtig beknackt.
So, und
ich hab da schon ein paar Mal dabei gesessen, wo die
ganzen Sachen präsentiert werden, und da hat halt einer,
ein Azubi hat seine Sache präsentiert und
war eigentlich auch ganz
okay, ich mein, war schon, war zum,
war zu größten Teilen echt langweilig
und man hat gemerkt, dass Präsentieren nicht
so seine Stärke ist, aber war okay.
So, und da saß dann ein Typ
dabei, so ein, so ein, so ein, so ein,
typischer, ich-finde-mich-mega-geil-BWL-Mensch
saß dabei.
So, und dann hat er dann, hat er dann, der hat die ganze
Zeit schon wild mitgeschrieben, um den, um den
Azubi danach quasi ordentlich kritisieren zu können.
Ähm, so, so, so,
so richtig übertriebener, ich-finde-mich-selbst-geil-
Anzug-BWL-Mann war das.
So, und dann hat er gesagt danach zum
Azubi so, ja, also das, äh,
ich weiß, das ist jetzt meckern, meckern auf
hohem Niveau, ähm, aber
das und das und das und das und das hat er
zur, zur Azubi-Präsentation gesagt.
Und danach hat er noch angefügt, so nach
dem Motto, wenn du mal eine, jetzt ist kein, kein
Witz, wie geil man sich finden kann, ist echter Wahnsinn.
Ähm,
danach hat er gesagt, ja, und wenn du mal eine
richtig gute Präsentation sehen willst,
da hab ich noch eine für dich,
da hab ich nämlich mal eine Präsentation
über mein Leben erstellt.
Das hat er dem wirklich so erzählt!
Er hat gesagt, ich hab eine Präsentation
über mein Leben erstellt, und wenn du
mal eine richtig gute Präsentation sehen willst,
kann ich dir die geben. Alter, wie fertig
kann man im Kopf sein?
Hahaha.
Vor allem,
vor allem,
da stellen sich ja alle
nackte Haare auf, wenn man das hört.
Das war, das, das war
einer der größten Pain-Champ-Momente,
die ich je, je, je auf der Arbeit
erlebt habe, äh.
Nee, da musste ich nicht
lachen, da hat sich alles bei mir zusammengezogen,
als ich das gehört habe.
Das könntest,
damit könntest du das hier noch toppen.
Da könntest du sagen, nee, kann ich nicht machen, aber
ähm, vielleicht möchtest du ein Autogramm
von mir, und wenn du willst, schicke ich dir auch noch
die Präsentation über mein Leben mit.
Meine Güte, Alter, oh!
Nee, die wollte sich niemand anhören.
Das, es ist auch keiner, es ist auch keiner
drauf eingegangen. Das ist richtig fail.
Finden sich nicht alle BWLer grundsätzlich
voll geil? Nö, nö, nö, es gibt ganz, ganz
viele auch, äh, sehr nette
und normale BWLer. Aber,
aber was mir halt oft in Kombination
halt so auffällt, ist, dass
gerade Leute,
die sich, äh,
unbegründeterweise
ausgesprochen geil
finden, oftmals BWLer sind.
Was nicht heißt, dass jeder BWLer so ist,
aber die Kombination tritt, tritt
oft gehäuft auf, ja.
Vor allem dann auch noch so unbegründeterweise sich geil
finden. Ja, guck mal weiter.
Das sind dann ein Marketing,
das war garantiert, das war garantiert ein Marketing
BWLer.
B29 Korn, schick her,
gucken wir uns dann live im Stream an.
Danke schön für den Sub.
Huge IQ Sub.
Äh, Moment, das wollte ich gar nicht aufmachen.
Hier wollte ich weitergucken, was mit seinen, mit seinen Flaggen
passiert.
Laos send a few different sizes of flags.
Eritrea send me their flag.
Was, Eritrea?
Das ist irgendwo in Afrika, oder?
As did Burkina Faso, the Alpine country
of Austria, and also Slovakia.
Wohlgemerkt, Austria, nicht Australia.
Some of the embassies in Copenhagen
invited me to visit. The first place I went
was the embassy of Cyprus.
Moment, die haben ihn, die haben ihn wirklich eingeladen,
aufgrund dieser Mail,
dass er die Flagge abholen kann.
Das ist eigentlich richtig cool, oder?
Ich mein, ihre Aufgabe
ist zu repräsentieren, aber das finde ich schon cool.
Einfach keinen Bock mehr,
Videos zu machen, oder was ist der Grund?
Ja, YouTube ist scheiße. YouTube suckt.
Ähm, aber ich
mach wahrscheinlich heute eins.
Wenn ich, wenn ich Bock drauf hab. Ich hab genug Material,
denke ich. Muss ich mal schauen,
ob's reicht. Ich würde ja gerne
so ein Viertelstunden-Video draus machen.
And some books, and with the incredibly friendly ambassador.
The Libyan embassy was also
very welcoming and gave me a large flag
along with some fly Libyan accessories.
Then there was the Polish embassy,
which gave me a book of Polish people.
Boah, die gehen ja voll ab. Die Polen, die haben dem,
die haben den Flaggen geschickt, Bücher geschickt.
...Polish people along with their flag.
Next I went to the embassy of Iran, where I had tea
with their consuls. Stimmt, würde mich mal interessieren,
was die deutsche Fahne ist, ob er die gekriegt hat.
He was also very kind and pleasant,
though it was a bit strange setting,
having a meeting for no real reason.
Ich glaub, dem war einfach langweilig,
dem Botschafter.
...the first date, where you get to know each other.
After about 20 minutes, I said I wouldn't steal
any more of his time.
Was haben sie denn da oben hängen? Irgendwelche
obergroß, sonst was, Ayatollahs,
oder was hängt da? Gut, das ist Iran.
Botschaft vom Iran, das ist klar, dass da so Leute hängen.
...that I stayed.
I give the diplomatic delegations of Cyprus, Libya,
Poland and Iran a solid 10 out of 10.
Ethiopia mailed a flag,
as did Ireland, and Luxembourg,
not to forget Colombia.
Mauritius sent me their flag,
sorry for turning it upside down,
...sorry for turning it upside down,
Ich bin ja mal gespannt, ob Deutschland ihm was
geschickt hat.
...after getting a flag from Kosovo,
and none at the time from Serbia, they now have my full
recognition. Speaking of non-UN
members, I got a flag from the Ministry
of Foreign Affairs of Transnistria,
...of was? Von was?
Okay, irgendwas auf Kyrillisch.
Was? Was für
ein Land?
the Transnistrian?
Was? Was zum?
Was ist das für ne Land?
Ach ja.
Prinestrovian.
Was ist?
Was?
Die was?
Was? Was?
Oh, ich kann das nicht mehr schreiben.
Moldavia?
So, und was?
Was haben die da vorgeschrieben?
Prinestrovia
Was
Was Transnist
What
Was ist das
Transnistria
Hahaha
What the fuck
Was ist das
Hahaha
Okay, wo liegt das überhaupt
Okay, wo liegt das
Ne, das ist Weißrussland, da wollte ich jetzt nicht hin
Da
Hallo, ich will die
Kann ich das nicht in groß haben
Ah
Okay, da liegt das irgendwo
Hier sind wir
Irgendwo am
Schwarzen Meer, hä
Oh, ne, ist das, das ist nicht das Schwarze Meer
Das ist das, äh
Was ist denn das
Schwarze Meer ist das da, oder
Geografie, Alter
Das ist das Schwarze Meer, oder
Was ist das
Oh, ist das das Schwarze Meer
Das, das ist das Schwarze Meer
Was ist das
Balkansee oder sowas
Oh, die Geste, die Geste
Sieht ein bisschen gefährlich aus, so von
Ohne, dass man sieht, wie seine Hand aussieht
Sieht die Geste schon ein bisschen Monkatoss aus
Aus deutscher Sicht, äh
Der Chat, wie der Chat schon wieder so tut
Als wüsste er es
Der Chat hat auch keine Ahnung
Okay, dann ist es doch das Schwarze Meer
Dann ist, dann ist es das Schwarze Meer
Dann ist das hier das Schwarze Meer
Was ist das dann
Das hier unten ist die Türkei
Okay, was auch immer
Geografie ist nicht meine Stärke
Anderes Meer
Das ist das Kaspische Meer
Ah, yes, excellent
Dann hab ich, dann hab ich das verwechselt
Okay, dann ist das, das eine ist das
Äh
Schwarze Meer und das andere ist das Kaspische Meer
Ah, ja
Einzige, einzige Sache, die ich mir gemerkt habe aus Erdkunde
Ist, dass wir in Deutschland einen Jahr
Debusen haben
Rest hab ich, hab ich, hab ich verdrängt
Okay, guck mal weiter, was hier rauskommt
Was er noch für Flaggen kriegt
Aber mal ganz ernsthaft
Habt ihr, habt ihr von diesem Land schon mal was gehört?
Ich mein
The fuck
Transnistrien
Was zum
Im Leben nicht
Wie viele Einwohner hat das überhaupt?
Äh
Hundertfünfundsiebzig
Vierhundertfünfundsiebzigtausend
Okay, das ist jetzt nicht so viel
Hundertdreitig Einwohner pro Kilometer
Wie viel haben wir?
Wie, wie viel Einwohner pro Kilometer, pro Quadratkilometer haben wir?
Noch nie von Moldau gehört
Doch, das ist ein Fluss
Das ist ein Fluss
Und da muss man in der Schule, muss man immer, immer Musik anhören
Die sich um die Moldau dreht
205 haben wir, okay
Big Brain Chat
Das kennt sich aus
232 pro Quadratkilometer
haben wir
Ah, yes
Was würde man nur ohne den Chat machen?
Das ist ziemlich cool
Und es hat immer noch einen Hammer und einen Siegel in der Kante
Oh
Ich werde meine persönliche Rekognition von jedem Land für eine Flagge bezahlen
Ich habe auch eine Flagge von Island
Moment, was, was war das jetzt hier?
Ich werde meine persönliche Rekognition von jedem Land für eine Flagge bezahlen
Ich habe auch eine Flagge von Island
Und eine von Spanien
Und eine von Deutschland
Oh
Okay, die Deutschen haben ihm wirklich nur das, exakt das geschickt, was er gefragt hat
Die Zimbabweanen der Königreich Republik haben mir eine Flagge eingeschickt
Und was sie belief
Ich habe eine Flagge aus Bahrain
Eine Flagge aus Andorra
Die Flagge von San Marino
Die Flagge von Liechtenstein
Von 3 verschiedenen Orten
Die Flagge von den Marshall-Inseln
Die Flächensteiner schleimen rum, weil sie wahrscheinlich denken
Ey, wenn der Typ mal richtig Kohle hat, mit seinen Flanken sammeln, dann muss er ja irgendwo Steuern sparen.
Dann soll er zu uns.
Ich wollte schon immer mal permanente News aus Albanien haben.
Jordan hat mir eine große Flagge aus Österreich und auch eine große Flagge aus Norwegen geschickt.
Ägypten hat mir auch eine große, hohe Qualität Flagge geschickt.
Die deutschen Länder waren sehr generös und sahen, dass ein höheres Projekt...
Das ist ja eine Riesenflagge.
Okay, es ist irgendwas auf Arabisch.
Was war das jetzt?
...flaggen für Fremde online.
Was war das für eine Flagge jetzt?
Ägypten.
Die deutschen Länder waren sehr generös und sahen, dass ein höheres Projekt...
Boah, guckt euch das mal an hier.
Kann sich ja fast zudecken mit...
...Flaggen für Fremde online.
Die Vereinigten Arabischen Emirate haben tatsächlich so eine große Package mit Flaggen geschickt, dass ich...
Guck mal hier!
Die Arabischen Emirate, die gehen ja richtig ab!
Sie haben auch ein paar Skarben mit Bildern der Präsenz.
Da hast du hier den...
Hast du...
Kriegst sogar...
Kriegst sogar den Prinz auf der Flagge.
Ja, das ist doch...
Das ist doch mal Service.
Da kriegst du hier die Fahnen und kriegst sogar eine Flagge mit dem Prinz drauf.
Marokko hat mir diese schwere Flagge gegeben.
Wenn ich so viele Männer schenke, war meine größte Angst, dass manche von ihnen...
...die Fahnen an die falschen Leute schicken würden.
Aber glücklicherweise sah es nur so aus, als ob es nur zwei Fehler gab.
Ich habe zu der schwedischen Embassy in der Vereinigten Kingdom geschrieben, die sagte...
...die Embassy von Schweden kann dir nicht unterstützen, eine Flagge zu finden...
...von Svartini zu finden.
In Bezug auf die Embassy von Schweden und London.
Das ist ziemlich recht, glaube ich.
Ich konnte auch nicht eine mexikanische Flagge von diesem Mann bekommen.
Lieber Sebastian, wir sind ein Schiffshal.
Ich anrufe dich, die Embassy zu kontaktieren, in Bezug auf deine Anforderungen.
Aber im Allgemeinen funktioniert es überraschend gut, mit dem E-Mail zu schreiben.
Naja, manchmal sind die Mails halt an falsche Leute gegangen, aber das...
...wundert mich nicht.
So sieht also die Fahne von Zimbabwe aus.
Ist das eine Taube?
Das ist eine Taube, oder?
Eine Taube, die gerade irgendwo reinkackt.
Also, wahrscheinlich sollte es was ganz anderes sein, aber...
...für mich sieht es so aus wie eine Taube, die gerade irgendwo reinkackt.
Oder ausbrütet, vielleicht brütet die irgendwas aus.
Vielleicht ist es auch...
...keine Taube.
...irgendwas mit was auch immer.
Okay, das wird...
Leute, ich...
...das interessiert mich jetzt.
Sim...
Ups, nein, nein, nein, nein.
...Bab...
...w...
...Flagge.
Flagge Zimbabwes.
Zulul.
Okay, was ist da drauf?
Grün steht für Symbolik.
Was?
Mit einem roten, fünfstrahligen Stern, bekleidet mit einem goldenen...
...nistenden, ah, der brütet, der brütet, und schafft gewandten Vogel.
Der Zimbabwe-Vogel, da gibt es einen eigenen Eintrag für den Zimbabwe-Vogel.
Also, Leute, es ist keine Taube, es ist der weltbekannte Zimbabwe-Vogel.
Alles klar, hier lernt man noch was heute.
Bildung FPS.
Zimbabwe.
Eine Flagge von Türken.
Eine Flagge von Armenien.
Eine große Flagge von Brasilien.
Eine Flagge von Bulgarien.
Eine Flagge von einigen anderen Orten.
Chile gab ein paar kleine Flagge.
Die Map wurde langsam...
Das ist geil, ne?
Alle, alle schicken sie ihm irgendwie extra Zeug, oder mal zumindest mehr als eine Fahne.
Und was macht Deutschland?
Schickt ihm eine, die billigste, also eine der billigsten Papier-McDonalds-Fahnen, die sie haben.
Aber einige der größten Länder haben noch nicht zu meinem E-Mail geantwortet.
Russland, China und Indien haben meine Map sehr lecker gemacht.
Glücklicherweise, obwohl Russland und Indien mir keine Flagge schicken konnten, haben sie beide...
Sie haben beide zu meinem E-Mail geantwortet, ein paar Wochen später.
Also sah meine Map besser aus.
China war der einzige große Platz auf der Map, außer...
Wir antworten bestimmt auch nicht.
... und rund um Zentralafrika.
Wir haben in Deutschland kein Geld dafür, jemand aus Dänemark eine Stoffflagge zu schicken.
Wobei der Durchschnitt in Deutschland tatsächlich kein Geld hat.
Also die Geschichte mit so nach dem Motto, wir sind so wahnsinnig reich und so, ist ja im Durchschnitt so.
Aber nur, wenn man die reichsten Leute mitmacht.
Wenn man mal so ein bisschen normalisiert das Ganze.
Also sprich, wenn man mal die Top-Tops der oberen Reichen weglässt und die Ärmsten der Armen weglässt,
kommt man eigentlich drauf, dass man im Durchschnitt in Deutschland auch gar nicht so viel Kohle hat.
Und man halt auch saumäßig viel abgeben muss davon noch.
Also so reich, wie immer getan wird, sind wir gar nicht.
Ich mein, wenn wir das wären, müssten Rentner nicht Pfandflaschen sammeln gehen, ne?
... und es ist nicht so, als ob ich nichts aus China schicken würde.
Oh, die Chinesen wollen folgendes sagen.
Die Chinesen wurden voll gespammt.
Die Mails bleiben in der China-Firewall hängen.
Das ist ja geil, ne?
Die ganzen quasi China-Feinde, also aus chinesischer Sicht, die antworten ihm, aber China nicht.
Das ist eine gute Idee.
Das ist auch geil, so nach dem Motto Mexiko.
Übrigens, wir haben ja eine Flagge geschickt, aber eigentlich verschicken wir keine Flaggen.
Luigi Ferrari.
Das ist ja der most italian name ever, oder?
Italienischer kannst du nicht heißen.
Italienischer kannst du einfach nicht heißen.
Das geht nicht.
Mario Ferrari wär vielleicht auch noch ok gewesen.
Aber Luigi Ferrari ist ja die Kombination so von Peter Müller im Enddefeng, ja?
Also, ganz toll.
Genau.
Und, ja...
Das geht.
Okay.
Also, Italienischer kannst du nicht heißen, geht nicht.
Ja, genau.
Ey, Assassin, wenn irgendjemand die Italiener verarschen wollte, ja, und gesagt hätte,
mein Name ist Luigi Ferrari, dann würden sie sagen, sei mal nicht so rassistisch, Luigi Ferrari, so heißt doch keiner.
Doch.
Stimmt, in Nintendo of America, der neue Chef heißt Bowser, ja.
Hat gar nicht so die große Runde gemacht, ne, ich fand das übrigens lustig, als der Reggie da seine Übergabe eingeleitet hat,
und der nächste Typ heißt Bowser.
Das ist das Katzenspielzeug, oder?
What?
Warum?
Das hab ich schon immer.
Ich hab schon immer mal gebraucht, ich hab schon immer mal nen Ventilator fürs Handy gebraucht aus Malta.
Das sieht auch schon so aus, als macht's mein Handy kaputt.
Vielleicht ist das, vielleicht ist das auch gar kein, vielleicht ist das auch gar kein Ventilator, sondern ist ein Schiffsantrieb oder sowas.
Das ist ja ein Schiffsantrieb.
Moment, ist die Pakis-, hab ich das jetzt richtig erkannt?
Ist die pakistanische Flagge, die türkische Flagge nur in schwarz?
Oder, oder sieht die, sieht die anders aus?
Sieht für mich aus wie die türkische Flagge, nur in schwarz.
Und, und der Mond ist ein bisschen gedreht.
Eigentlich grün?
Das ist doch nicht grün.
Bin ich farbenblind, oder was?
Oh.
Sie ist tatsächlich grün.
Leute, sieht das für euch...
Ja, doch. Das ist grün.
Das ist grün, aber durch die Kamera
und weil das außenrum so weiß ist,
macht die Kamera das schwarzer,
als es aussieht. Also es sieht schon ziemlich schwarz aus,
aber es ist... Ja, ich kann mir vorstellen,
dass es grün ist.
Das ist wie bei dem Kleid. Doch, doch, das wird grün sein.
Wenn man... Die Kamera hat wahrscheinlich
als weiß irgendwie das hier genommen.
Ah, gut. Gleich mal Rechtsbelehrung dabei.
Das kennen wir aus Deutschland. Das war mal gerne so.
Trinidad und Tobago.
Ist Trinidad und Tobago...
Ist das Südamerika oder Afrika?
Was für ein Ding!
St. Vincent... What?
Wie heißen die?
Ich habe es im Leben noch nicht gehört.
Ah, die sind so exzellent.
Was haben eigentlich
die ganzen Länder da unten mit ihrem
Halbmond? Warum haben die alle irgendwie
einen Halbmond drauf?
Na, immerhin.
Guck dir mal. Die deutsche Botschaft
hat es nur geschafft, ihm eine billige Papier-McDonalds-Flagge
zu schicken.
Wenigstens hat Nordrhein-Westfalen es geschafft,
ihm eine ordentliche Stoffflagge oder so eine
synthetische
Stoffflagge zu schicken.
Sie haben mir eine Stoffflagge gegeben.
Rhode Island hat mir auch eine Stoffflagge in einer schönen Box gegeben.
Und letztlich, aber nicht am wenigsten, Wyoming.
Kekona hat mir keine Stoffflagge gesendet,
sondern eine große Map.
Ich habe ein paar E-Mails von den anderen USA-Staaten
und ich war ehrlich gesagt verwirrt, was es bedeutet,
wenn sie ihre E-Mails, SOS, gesendet haben.
Waren diese armen Menschen in Gefahr?
Es scheint, es war nur die Staatssekretärin, die schreibt.
In Russland hat die Republik
von Altai mir ihre tolle Stoffflagge gesendet,
mit ein paar Pfeifenkonten-Kandis.
Die Jammel-Ninit schickt ihre Stoffflagge
Das sieht aus wie ein Kompressions-Artefakt
in einem Video, die Flagge.
Das ist schon geil, oder?
Das fasziniert mich auch jedes Mal wieder,
dieser Google-Translator,
der Bilder-on-the-fly-translated.
Ich finde, das ist eines der besten Sachen,
so nach dem Motto,
dass wir in der Zukunft angekommen sind.
Ich weiß, dass es technisch gar nicht so
die Wahnsinns-Herausforderung ist,
heutzutage, vor allem mit der Power,
die du in deinem Handy drin hast,
quasi OCR zu machen
auf einem gut aufgenommenen Papier
und das dann über den Translator zu jagen.
Aber hätte man das jemand vor,
20 oder vor 30 Jahren gezeigt,
der hätte gesagt,
wollt ihr mich verarschen?
Du nimmst so ein Ding,
hältst das über einen Zettel
und behältst das über einen Text drüber
und auf einmal zeigst du es in deiner Sprache an.
Das ist so ein typisches Ding,
wo es technisch unten drunter
nicht so wahnsinnig beeindruckend ist,
aber die komplette Anwendung an sich,
wo man sagt,
ey, 2020, wir sind in der Zukunft.
Das ist ja eine hässliche Flagge.
So als konnten die nicht malen.
Komischer Baum und ein langgezogener Löwe.
Das ist ja eine hässliche Flagge.
Und sie haben mir diese zwei großen,
modernen Versionen gesendet.
Mein leerer Raum ist jetzt viel künstlerischer
als all diese Flaggen.
Ich bin eigentlich aus der Oberfläche gegangen,
um die restlichen Flaggen anzunehmen.
Ich habe jetzt viel zu lesen.
Wenn ich jetzt noch viel zu lesen habe,
muss ich etwas schreiben.
Ich habe jetzt viele Pins, die ich auswählen kann.
Wenn ich raus muss,
habe ich eine faszinierende Selektion von Pins
und Accessorien, die ich tragen kann.
Ein paar kurze Statistiken.
In Bezug auf die UN.
143 aus 193 Ländern antworteten zu meinem E-Mail.
89 UN-Staaten sagten,
dass sie etwas senden oder mir etwas senden würden,
was ich aktuell von 77 von ihnen erhielt habe.
In Bezug auf Staaten, Territorien
und unerkenntnisierte Länder
gab es 21, die mir Flaggen sendeten.
Okay.
Aber war doch gute Ausbeute.
Die Deutschen waren auch synchronisiert.
Die haben eben auch nur eine geschickt, ne?
Warum kommt die kanadische Flagge aus Berlin?
Was macht man jetzt mit den Flaggen da an die Wand hängen, hat man doch gesehen.
Aber die Chinesen wollen nicht.
Die Chinesen wollen nicht.
Und die hier sind gerade beschäftigt, sich gegenseitig umzubringen.
Ich finde das richtig cool, wie viele da geantwortet haben.
Finde ich nice, wie viele da geantwortet haben.
Aber sie müssen halt repräsentieren, dafür sind die da.
Aber ich finde es cool, dass sie...
Oh ne, ne, noch so ein Cringe-Video ertrage ich jetzt nicht.
Wir gucken uns jetzt das Video an von Linus unter 20.
Unter 20 ist das Video von Linus unter 20.
Unter 20 Dollar SSD.
Fake News.
Ha, die habe ich hier auf dem Schreibtisch liegen.
Genau die, das ist der MX500.
Das ist der MX500.
Okay.
What?
Ist das ein Gamerteppich?
Sehe ich das richtig?
Das ist ein Gamerteppich.
Gamerteppich.
I know it shouldn't matter.
But whenever I see really terrible branding,
like to the point where you'd have had to be a child or an idiot
to think that it makes any sense,
it really does take my confidence in the finished product, you know?
Why is there an overweight bird on the box for this package?
What is it about this that screams racing?
I don't know.
You don't know.
Nobody knows.
We're all just guessing.
So let's talk through the specs here.
This is a two and a half inch drive with an apparent 128 megabyte.
Wie nur?
Ach so, 8 Megabyte Cache.
Und wie viel insgesamt hat die SSD?
120G?
120G ist doch, da muss man doch nicht mal eine Scam-SSD für kaufen.
120G SSDs kosten noch nix.
Ja, sogar die guten kosten nur 25 Euro.
Und man kriegt die, man kriegt die garantiert noch günstiger.
Ich werde ein Ticken lauter machen.
Ja, die Preise, dass die Hardwarepreise streiken, ist klar.
Die Chinesen produzieren ja auch gerade nicht.
Wobei manche angeblich wieder anfangen wollen jetzt.
Äh, was geht beim Freesie?
Ich hab jetzt seit ein, zwei Wochen nix mehr von dem gehört,
aber ich vermute mal das gleiche wie vorher immer noch.
Also dem geht's bestimmt gut.
This thing is totally brand new inbox, so...
We also have this that came in the package.
Oh, service policy.
SATA-Kabel, Kabel.
We are so glad that you selected us and our products.
We offer a five year limited warranty.
Love you.
Dave, you got a SATA-Cable.
That is actually a pretty good bonus.
Most drives don't include a SATA-Cable anymore.
So, I mean...
True.
We need our data and our power.
And is this just gonna boot right up for me, Anthony?
Uh, if you...
Das, das ist ne Sache, ne?
Die werde ich nie verstehen.
Ähm...
Ich hab mir vor ein paar Jahren, als die 2TB-SSDs neu waren,
hatte ich mir für irgendwie 750€ oder so ne 2TB-Samsung-SSD gekauft.
Und bei einer 750€-SSD war kein SATA-Kabel dabei.
Kein SATA-Kabel.
Da war bei 750€ auch die SATA-Kabel.
Da war bei 750€ auch definitiv kein Budget mehr für vorhandenen SATA-Kabel dabei zu machen.
Well, yeah, minor details.
The sticker?
Sure is.
So, if the sticker's on it, you get plus 2 years of warranty?
I don't know.
Power off recovery.
That to me indicates that it would have a capacitor on it.
Like an enterprise...
Ja, auf, zeig mal her, was das Ding kann.
It can't possibly have that.
Muss euch nicht 5 Stunden zugucken, wie ihr das Ding jetzt einbaut.
Also, I love this sentence right here.
Thank you for selecting us, good luck.
So, first test is...
Was? Thank you for my deal?
Love you?
What?
So, first test is, what, just initializing it?
Yeah, we need to initialize it.
New simple volume...
Well, the capacity is as advertised.
Now, there's some more problems here.
This says serial ATA revision 2.6.
Was?
It also says it's SATA 6 gigabit per second.
2.6? Ich wusste gar nicht, dass es SATA 2.6 überhaupt gibt.
...on the drive as well.
Was, spackt der Stream?
Nö.
...it doesn't even support trim...
...and is SATA 2.
Well, depending on which spec you believe.
Well, we'll know soon enough, because CrystalDiskMark
will tell us exactly what kind of
sequential speeds we can expect from this thing.
You know, in some ways, this, like, rando,
cheap hardware is far more interesting
than the stuff from...
Da hat er recht, da geb ich ihm voll und ganz recht.
Okay, look at that.
So it's SATA 3,
6 gigabit per second, even though there's
information right on the box that would
indicate that it's not.
What?
They put a dub on their packaging, so how...
How can we rely on them to know exactly
what's in the box if they clearly had no idea
what they were doing on the outside of it?
Out of the gate, I'm actually kind of
impressed. I mean, saturating
the SATA 3 6 gigabit per second interface
has not been a feat for...
Also, sequenziell? Aber sequenziell
können sie alle.
The thing is, this is only a
120 gig SSD.
Hab ich euch eigentlich erzählt, was mit meiner Heizung
jetzt kaputt war?
Der Heizungsmann war jetzt nämlich da,
weil meine Heizung rumgespackt hat.
Habt ihr ja mitgekriegt im letzten Stream.
Und jetzt sieht das so aus, meine Heizung.
Wieder richtig gut. Top.
Wassertemperatur top.
Brenner top.
Kesseltemperatur top. Kein Fehler mehr.
Abgastemperatur top. Pumpe top.
Die Steuerung war...
Die Steuerung für den Brenner war kaputt.
Er hat mir das gezeigt.
Man kann irgendwo Fehlercode 38
oder sowas auslesen.
Und wenn da was
irgendwie steht, dann ist es kaputt.
Ich hab's bis jetzt noch nicht geschafft,
Fehlercode 38 mit meinem Raspberry Pi
auszulesen.
So, und dann...
Jetzt hab ich ne neue Steuerung.
Die kostet normalerweise, glaub 600 Euro.
Aber ich hab die für
300 Euro gekriegt, weil die nur 7 Jahre
gehalten hat. Hab ich so, das ist...
in Ordnung.
Aber, was heißt nur 300 Euro?
Ähm...
Ja, die Steuerung für den Brenner.
Er hat mir gesagt, die Steuerung wäre kaputt,
aber das ergibt keinen Sinn.
Wenn man nachguckt, was Fehlercode 38 ist,
dann ist es die Steuerung für den Brenner,
die kaputt ist, und nicht irgendwie die Steuerung
für die gesamte Heizung.
Warum natürlich ne Brennersteuerung irgendwie
650 Euro kostet,
erschließt sich mir nicht.
Ich glaube, der einzige Grund ist,
dass es ein Vendor-Login ist.
Also sprich, weil man keine andere Wahl hat,
als die Steuerung vom Hersteller zu kaufen.
Technisch ist es absolut nicht
plausibel, dass das Ding
650 Euro kostet.
Ja.
Also Leute, wenn ihr wollt, dass ich im Warmen
setze, dass ich die Rechnung bezahlen kann,
müsst ihr mir noch ein paar Twitch Prime Subs abgeben.
Sonst muss ich hier
im Kalten sitzen.
Und ich kann meine Internetrechnung
nicht mehr bezahlen, das heißt, ich kann auch nicht mehr streamen.
Ich hab jetzt die Auswahl,
Internetrechnung oder Heizung.
...
Hat sie...
Die könnten ja auch faken!
Die könnten ja auch faken mit sequentiell write.
Die writen einfach gar nicht, die nehmen einfach die Daten an
F0 im Endeffekt unter der Haube, also weg.
Das heißt, die Daten sind gar nicht drauf.
...
... ... ... ... ... ... ... ... ... ... ... ... ... ... ... ... ... ... ... ... ... ... ... ... ... ... ... ... ... ... ... ... ... ... ... ... ... ... ... ... ... ... ... ... ... ... ... ... ... ... ... ... ... ... ... ... ... ... ... ... ... ... ... ... ... ... ... ... ... ... ... ... ... ... ... ... ... ... ... ... ... ... ... ... ... ... ... ... ... ... ... ... ... ... ... ... ... ... ... ... ... ... ... ... ... ... ... ... ... ... ... ... ... ... ... ... ... ... ... ... ... ... ... ... ... ... ... ... ... ... ... ... ... ... ... ... ... ... ... ... ... ... ... ... ... ... ... ... ... ... ... ... ... ... ... ... ... ... ... ... ... ... ... ... ... ... ... ... ... ... ... ... ... ... ... ... ... ... ... ... ... ... ... ... ... ... ... ... ... ... ... ... ... ... ... ... ... ... ... ... ... ... ... ... ... ... ... ... ... ... ... ... ... ... ... ... ... ... ... ... ...
Guck mal, mit Terminal Interface hat er es sogar gebaut, mit einem N-Cursus Interface.
Okay, das ist ganz normales Suspense, oder?
Ohje, es explodiert.
Es gibt einen ganz einfachen Trick dagegen, einfach kein WhatsApp verwenden.
Und den ganzen Crap nicht verwenden.
So schaut ein richtiger ITler aus, nicht wie die Typen vorhin in diesem 1Live-Video.
Der Chat, was ist das?
Na, irgendein Haken muss das China-Dinger haben.
Okay.
VielleichtAndy то hat derяли kleines Dattalyssimuliert oder, so wie 8X.
Es ist überall.
Okay.
Also hat er einen DRAM- Halo?
Nein, nicht mi, wir werden es herausfinden...
Nun was?
So, jetzt können wir diese Ergebnisse anzeigen aber wir können auch einen unserer DRAM-Listen
SSDs einsetzen.
Ah, lass uns dasiralut.
Ohne Scheiß, das ist der beste, der beste Sellout überhaupt, den wir immer machen, ey.
Ich hab Count Pass of Exile gespielt, XD.
Das ist ja gut, ey.
Das war eine runde Asski-Art.
Würdest du die Hardware-Rad-PCs empfehlen?
Ich muss dir ehrlich sagen, ich habe mir die Hardware-Rad-PCs nicht angeguckt bisher.
Aber alles, was ich so von denen mitgekriegt habe, würde ich dir schon empfehlen.
Also ich glaube nicht, dass die Mist zusammenbauen.
Ich hab sie mir aber noch nicht angeschaut.
Und ich hab auch keine Ahnung, immer bis zu dem Zeitpunkt, wo ich mir selbst einen Desktop-Rechner kaufen will.
Wir gucken uns gleich mal die Hardware-Rad-PCs an, was sie aktuell so haben.
Was macht der da jetzt eigentlich? Jetzt haben sie eine andere SSD angeschlossen. Ja, und?
Okay, ich weiß, worauf die raus will.
Sie wollen uns erzählen, dass die angeblich bessere SSD unter der Haube doch nur eine billige SSD ist.
Wer hätte das gedacht bei 20 Dollar?
20 Dollars.
Langweilig.
Langweilig ist das Video. Geh weg.
Gucken wir lieber, was Hardware-Rad aktuell für PCs hat.
Also, schauen wir mal. Was gibt es da?
Lagernde PCs. Also sprich, das sind welche, die schon fertig gebaut sind.
Der Hardware-Rad Büro-Einsteiger 4 GB.
Der Hardware-Rad Gaming. Okay.
730 Euro Gaming-PC. Das dürfte so das Budget sein, was viele Leute auch bereit sind auszugeben.
Schauen wir mal, was kriegen wir denn dafür?
Eine...
Eine Ryzen 5 1600.
Ich gehe mal davon aus, das ist eine 1600, weil die einfach günstiger sind und verfügbarer sind als die anderen.
Eine Boxkühler. Vollkommen in Ordnung.
Mailboard kann ich nichts zu sagen.
16G RAM.
Ordentlich.
Aber man muss ehrlich sagen, RAM war jetzt lange Zeit auch ziemlich günstig.
Das heißt, man kann RAM ja prinzipiell nicht genug haben.
Dann haben wir eine SSD.
Eine 240G SSD und eine 1TB Festplatte.
Okay, damit würde ich hinten und vorne nicht auskommen.
Aber irgendwo musst du ja Kompromisse machen.
Grafikkarte.
1660.
Ich denke mal, ich bin zwar jetzt nicht so der Pro, was Grafikkartenleistung angeht und vergleicht,
aber ich denke mal, dass es in der Preiskategorie vollkommen in Ordnung geht.
Eine 1660.
Das Netzteil habe ich, glaube ich, bei...
Ich glaube, bei Hardware-Lux oder so mal im Test gesehen.
Das war ganz okay.
Okay.
Flüssiger Lüfter und sonst was.
Tja.
Gut, jetzt habe ich es mir angeguckt.
Ich habe immer noch keinen Plan.
Also ich kann dir nicht sagen, ob die PCs gut sind.
Aber nachdem ich ihn kenne und nicht glaube, dass die Jungs irgendwie absichtlich Mist zusammenbauen.
Ich kann es dir persönlich empfehlen.
Kann ich nicht.
Habe ich nicht ausprobiert.
Aber nachdem, wie gesagt, ich glaube nicht, dass die Mist zusammenbauen.
Da kannst du wahrscheinlich wenig falsch machen.
Und preis-leistungsmäßig sind die Dinger mit Sicherheit auch nicht verkehrt.
Ich meine, ich würde es mir nach wie vor...
Ich würde es mir nach wie vor selbst zusammenbauen.
Aber wenn man das nicht will, ist das wahrscheinlich nicht verkehrt.
So, wie lange bin ich jetzt eigentlich schon on?
Zwei Stunden, Leute.
Ich habe nämlich so langsam aber sicher Hunger.
Komm, wir gucken uns jetzt noch den Raspberry Pi als Desktop...
Ne, das wollte ich mir angucken.
First Look Windows 10X.
Ist halt 50 Euro teurer als selbst zusammenbauen.
Das ist doch super.
Dass du 50 Euro für...
Du bezahlst ja nicht nur 50 Euro für...
Dass du nicht selbst zusammenbauen musst.
Du bezahlst ja auch 50 Euro dafür, dass du auf das Gesamtpaket deine zwei Jahre Garantie hast.
Beziehungsweise sechs Monate.
Insgesamt zwei Jahre, aber davon sechs Monate.
Wo es keine Probleme macht.
Und ich glaube, die machen da auch keine Probleme, wenn der Rechner kaputt ist.
Also sprich, für 50 Euro ist das absolut im Rahmen.
50 Euro ist eigentlich, wenn man ehrlich ist, sind 50 Euro noch viel zu billig.
Eigentlich müsste das mehr kosten.
Ich weiß gar nicht, wie die das überhaupt machen können für 50 Euro.
50 Euro, das ist ja...
Dafür steht ja manch einer gar nicht morgens auf.
Das ist übertrieben gesagt.
50 Euro mehr zum Zusammenbauen, das ist ja nix.
Aber was ich schön finde, dass ich zumindest meinen Teil dazu beigetragen habe, dass das Aufbauen schneller geht.
Mit meinem Windows-Aktivierungstool.
So, gucken wir uns mal First Look Windows 10X.
Ich habe ehrlich gesagt keine Ahnung.
Ich habe keine Ahnung.
Ich habe ehrlich gesagt keine Ahnung, was Windows 10X ist.
Es haben mich aber im Stream schon öfters Leute gefragt, was ich zum neuen Windows denke.
Und ich habe keine Ahnung.
Ich glaube, es ist was für Tablets.
Hey there, everyone.
Zach here for Windows Central.
And welcome back to another video.
Okay, es ist ein Tablet OS.
Take a look at Windows 10X.
This is Microsoft's new version of Windows 10, designed primarily for dual screen and foldable PCs.
Eeeeh, Tab...
Touch.
...that strips out legacy components in favor of a lightweight and streamlined user experience.
This is a pretty big deal.
It's essentially the future of Windows.
And pretty much every legacy component that was once part of Windows 10 has been removed and containerized...
Na bloß nicht.
...the entire user experience, including the Windows shell, has been updated with modern code.
So you shouldn't be running into any legacy UIs anymore.
Everything on this version of Windows is entirely modern.
Jetzt bin ich ja mal gespannt.
Ob man nicht mehr so einen Müll braucht, wie das hier zum Beispiel, um in die Audio-Settings zu kommen.
Das hier, das hier, das hier, und das hier, Mikrofon, das hier, das hier.
Das ist eine absolute Zumutung.
Aber ich find's keine gute Idee, die Sachen touch-optimiert zu machen auf dem Desktop.
...which is great for those who are interested in consistent user interfaces and all of that good stuff.
Now, that doesn't mean the only two programs don't work.
The only two programs don't work, because they do.
We'll get to that in a little while, though.
It's loud genug.
So now let's sort of take a look at the Windows shell and the overall user experience,
because that's where the exciting stuff really is right now on Windows 10X.
So, right now we're using Windows 10X on a dual-screen device.
This is an emulator which emulates dual screens.
And Windows can see that and has decided to split the UI into two here.
So along the bottom we have this sort of white bar.
This is our taskbar.
But when we're using it in tablet mode, I guess, the taskbar minimizes.
Zeitung an desktop mode.
Also in desktop mode interessiert mich das eigentlich viel mehr.
You can swipe up on it.
So if I swipe up on it here, that will show us the start button,
as well as our pinned apps and our task-view button.
If I tap on the start button here, that will open up the new start menu.
Oh, das sieht aus wie der Android-Launcher ein bisschen.
Das sieht ein bisschen aus wie der Android-Launcher oder ein Gnome,
oder der Standard-Gnome-Launcher.
Kannst du dir das nicht selber runterladen?
Das ist eine gute Frage.
Was feststellt hast du?
Ich geh weg.
Ähm, das ist eine gute Frage.
Das muss ich mal gucken.
Windows 10 X Test Microsoft Emulator zum Download.
Chip.
Na, die verlässlichste Quelle.
Microsoft arbeitet an einem neuen...
Ähm, die verlässlichste Quelle überhaupt, ja.
Der Microsoft Emulator Windows 10 App.
Was?
Der Microsoft...
10 X Emulator.
Warum kann ich das nicht?
Warum kann ich das nicht in R4M installieren?
Das ist nicht für einen Desktop-Betrieb, ne?
Das ist rein für Tablets.
Tablets und Fernsehgeräte und Gedöns, aber doch nicht für Desktop, oder?
Das schreibe ich mir mal auf.
Vielleicht machen wir das in einem der nächsten Sachen.
Vielleicht gucken wir uns das in einem der nächsten Streams mal an.
Bis jetzt habe ich noch nicht so ganz gecheckt,
warum mich das interessieren sollte als Desktop-User.
Windows 10 X features a brand new start menu.
In fact, everything on Windows 10 X regarding...
Was für eine Klausel.
Das ist Chromium.
So, we can see here, our start menu is the combination of three different things
that were already available on Windows 10.
Das Startmenu sieht aus wie ein Gnome-Startmenu.
Search UI, the apps list and our timeline.
Oder eben in Android.
On Windows 10, those are three different UIs for some reason.
But on Windows 10 X, they've all been placed into the same start menu UI here.
So at the top, we have our search bar.
If I tap on that, I can start searching.
So if I want to launch, say, a calculator...
Das haben sie ja alle.
...a calculator here and that will show up there.
Below that is our apps list.
That also includes web apps.
So if you pin apps through Microsoft Edge, they will show up in this app list.
Soll das ein Chrome OS-Ersatz sein?
Ich finde, es sieht ein bisschen so aus, ja.
Ich habe keine Ahnung, für was Windows...
Wir müssen mal den Wikipedia-Eintrag oder so dazu lesen.
Für was das überhaupt sein soll.
Weil als Desktop-Ersatz sieht das für mich nicht aus.
Design for dual-screen devices like Surface.
Okay.
Was ist hier unten eigentlich mit der...
Was ist eigentlich hier mit dem Link los?
To all devices.
Also, wenn die das für den Desktop loslassen.
Ja?
Das ist ja der Todesstoß.
Was soll das?
Wollen die mich verarschen?
Ich will so einen Kackquäler hier auf dem Desktop haben.
Desktop will nicht Zeug haben, was für Maus- und Tastaturbedienung ausgelegt ist.
Das ist okay, wenn auf dem Desktop auch Touch unterstützt wird.
Aber hauptsächlich ausgelegt sollte es für Maus- und Tastaturbedienung auf dem Desktop sein.
You can tap on show all here to show us all of our installed apps, which is pretty nice.
And again, below that we have our timeline activity.
Ah, gibt es da irgendwas Interessanteres noch?
...our quick actions, now called quick settings below.
As well as our notifications here as well.
Windows 10 and this is something...
Es sieht ein bisschen aus, diese halbdurchsichtigen Dinger hier und die abgerundeten Button,
sieht ein bisschen aus, als wollte Microsoft die etwas ältere iOS-Generation nachmachen.
Das hier hätte durchaus ein Pop-up sein können von iOS 9 oder so.
...thing I really hope shows brand new shell experiences.
And if I swipe up the taskbar on the right...
Die Git-Windows 10 Mail.
Gehen wir fort.
Das schlechteste Mail-Programm ever.
...to take advantage of...
So while...
...are sent...
...is the one that's a little more like Windows 10.
But this is the notification sound...
...basic one.
I'm going to preview and pop that toast.
That's the new sound you're going to hear when notifications come in on Windows 10X.
And I think...
Okay, Leute, einmal alle auf den Kopf stellen.
...will become a virtual keyboard and trackpad.
This is important because on devices...
Juckt mich überhaupt nicht, ja.
...are really well with it.
Die können für Touch-Devices machen, was sie wollen.
Das ist, das juckt, das ist mir, geht mir komplett am Arsch vorbei.
Let's see here.
...Windows 10X, Web-Apps...
So, any programs...
...other stuff.
Okay, das ist langweilig, da wird schwätzig angeguckt.
Ich hab's mir mal aufgeschrieben, das gucken wir uns in einem der nächsten Streams mal im Emulator an.
Raspberry Pi als Desktop-Ersatz.
Das funktioniert eh nicht, ja.
Der Pi ist überhaupt nicht stark genug für Desktop-Ersatz.
Also, um damit wirklich ordentlich machen zu können.
Hey, Leute, hier ist ETA Prime wieder.
Letztens habe ich ein Unboxing-Video von dem offiziellen Raspberry Pi 4-Desktop-Tool veröffentlicht.
Heute werden wir es zusammenführen mit dualen 22-Inch-Monitoren und...
Moment, es gibt eine Maus, es gibt eine Maus, die aussieht wie ein Raspberry Pi Case.
The fuck?
...und ein paar Power-Speaker.
The only reason I added these speakers was because when I bought these monitors, I overlooked the fact that they didn't have speakers built in.
Now, the whole premise behind these videos here is just to see if the Raspberry Pi 4 can...
...Headset beste, beziehungsweise nicht Headset, Kopfhörer beste.
Wozu?
Ich habe hier zwar auch zwei Lautsprecher stehen, aber die habe ich zweimal im Jahr an.
...truly replace somebody's PC, or use it as a supplemental PC.
Now, personally, I don't believe that this could...
Es gibt wirklich eine offizielle Raspberry Pi Maus?
Ey, PC lustig, aber nicht.
...but I do believe a setup like this is perfectly capable...
...of getting most people by...
...aber, ähm, ich glaube, RDP-Clients, die nicht Windows entsacken.
...on what they do with their desktop or their laptop PC.
Such as web surfing, email checking, YouTube video viewing.
Even light image editing is totally possible on a small PC like this.
So today, I'm gonna show you how to get this kit set up.
Now, I'm not gonna show you how to unbox the monitors and set your speakers up and things like that.
But we're gonna get right down to the software and the SD-Card...
...which is included with the Raspberry Pi desktop kit.
But before we do that, let's get right down to pricing.
So the Raspberry Pi 4 desktop kit consists of a Raspberry Pi 4, 4GB...
Der Kram ist ja relativ teuer geworden mit dem Case, das sind glaub 40 Euro oder so.
...case for the Pi, your HDMI cables, power supply, mouse, keyboard...
...and a ready-to-go SD-Card, all for 129 dollars.
Boah!
...the monitors I'm using here are 1080p AOC IPS monitors...
Boah, das ist teuer!
...they actually look really good...
Dafür kriegst du ja schon einen richtigen Computer fast.
...really good.
...they're almost bezel-less, 70 dollars each.
And the speakers I have in the background were 35 dollars on a flash deal a couple months ago on Amazon.
So in total, for this whole desktop kit that you see here on this table, 305 dollars.
Now obviously...
305? Ohne Monitore, oder was?
Weil dafür kriegst du einen super Rechner fertig, fix und fertig, ja.
...if you just wanna get out with a single screen, you can get off a lot cheaper.
But if you already have an HDMI-enabled television, which most people do...
Mit Monitor.
...you can just get by with a...
Ja, okay, mit Monitor geht das, aber ganz ehrlich, wenn er für den Raspberry Pi und das genützt hat, also, da soll er sich einen günstigen Office-Rechner holen, der ist allemal besser als ein Raspberry Pi am Desktopbetrieb.
...the Raspberry Pi 4 desktop kit itself for a hundred...
Du hast ja bei einem Raspberry Pi mehrere Sachen, die ihn unbrauchbar machen für den Desktop.
Erstens hast du ziemlich wenige Schnittstellen für den Desktopbetrieb, du kannst richtig gut nur Linux drauflaufen lassen, was für die meisten Leute im Desktopbetrieb, oder was generell im Desktopbetrieb, Desktopbetrieb ein bisschen fragwürdig ist.
Und du hast halt auch keine sonderlich leistungsfähige Hardware für den Desktop, da machst du einen Browser auf, machst dir zwei YouTube-Videos an und das Ding stottert.
...hundertunddreißig Dollar.
Aber ich war wirklich interessiert, um zu sehen, welche Art von Erfahrung ich aus einem Dual-Monitor-Raspberry-Pi-4-Setup bekommen kann, also dachte ich, ich würde das Ganze einfach aufnehmen, um zu sehen, wie lange es dauert, um so etwas aufzusetzen, und ob es im Endeffekt alles wert ist.
Also habe ich noch nicht mal diesen Raspberry Pi eingepackt, ich werde ihn noch mal...
Der braucht sogar noch, der bräuchte sogar noch, wenn er das Ding richtig belastet, ein ordentliches Case, was kühlt.
...auf das Ganze.
Es sollte ziemlich einfach sein, weil dieses SD-Kart...
...ist bereits mit Noobs eingeladen, und wir können das Operationssystem installieren, das wir in diesem Video nutzen werden, sehr einfach, aus diesem SD-Kart.
Also hier ist es, das Hauptbrot und Butter für dieses ganze Setup, der Raspberry Pi 4.
Nun, dieser Kit kommt mit dem Raspberry Pi 4 4 GB Modell.
Wir haben vier Cores bei 1,5 Gigahertz, 4 GB RAM, zwei USB 2.0-Porte, zwei USB 3.0-Porte, USB-C-Type-C, um den Unit zu schalten, ein 3,5 Millimeter Audio-Jack, zwei Micro-HDMI-Ausstellungen.
Es hat auch AC-Wi-Fi-Bildschirme und Bluetooth-Ausstellungen.
Also habe ich gerade die eingestellte SD-Karte in den Raspberry Pi eingestellt.
Ich werde jetzt alles reinstecken.
Wir haben zwei Micro-HDMI-Porte, die 3,5 Millimeter Audio-Jack und unser Power-Input.
Alles ist sehr einfach zu finden auf der Seite des Pi.
Und für meinen ersten Monitor werde ich den HDMI-Port am nahesten zum Power-Input verwenden.
Dann gehen wir zum nächsten, für den zweiten Monitor.
Da ich diese externen Hörer benutze, brauche ich den MacBook-File-Input.
Gut.
Das ist ja mittlerweile keine Kunst.
Das ist ja keine Kunst mehr.
...Audio-Jack.
Und ich brauche meine Widerstände zu öffnen.
Und ich werde das am Ende machen.
Aber all das, was noch zu tun ist, ist das Plug-in in unser Keyboard und Maus.
So, hier sind wir mit der SD-Karte der Noobs, die in den Raspberry Pi 4 eingestellt ist.
Wir werden sie zum ersten Mal booten.
Jetzt werden beide Monitore populieren, aber wir werden nur einen Screen für dieses Setup verwenden.
Das ist, wer es noch nicht gesehen hat, das ist das Raspberry-Pi-Boot-Logo.
Und das kommt auch, wenn die SD-Karte kaputt ist.
Also, wenn ihr euren Raspberry-Pi-Boot-Logo auswählen wollt, dann könnt ihr das auch machen.
Wenn ihr euch den Raspberry-Pi anschaltet und der außerdem hier nichts macht, dann ist die SD-Karte im Arsch.
Oder der Reader oder irgendwas.
Das ist quasi das Raspberry-Pi-Boot-Logo.
...Section.
So, we only have to do this setup process one time.
And what it's gonna allow us to do is choose the operating system we want to install.
This is the Noob Setup Screen.
And Noob stands for New Out-of-Box Software.
Ach, dafür steht das.
...We have two options.
Now, this is without connecting to the Internet whatsoever.
Ich dachte, das...
Ich dachte bisher legit, das Ding heißt Noobs, weil es für Einsteiger ist.
...we have...
...Raspbian and LibreElect.
Raspbian is gonna be our full desktop.
LibreElect is media player software.
But in this video, we're gonna be tackling Raspbian.
So, there are more options with Noobs, but we're not online.
Ah, okay, den Installer gucken wir uns jetzt nicht an.
...Board.
And here it is.
Both monitors should populate with desktop screens.
Everything's looking pretty good.
Ich habe noch nie, äh, like a phoenix, genau.
Ich habe ein Raspberry-Pi, außer wenn er Probleme gemacht hat, noch nie an den Bildschirm angeschlossen.
Wozu?
Als Desktop-System ist es ungeeignet.
Als Media-Center-System finde ich es auch nicht sonderlich gut.
...so far, but there's a few more steps we need to do to get this set up correctly.
We still need to enable Overscan, because we're not using the full screen.
We have a black bar around both of the screens we're using here.
But everything is functional right now.
So, before I did anything, I just changed the desktop background.
Wieso nicht als Media-Center?
Weil das Ding zu schwach ist.
Weil auch die Hardware-Beschleunigung bei vielen Sachen nicht ordentlich funktioniert.
Ähm...
Und, weil Alternativen, wie irgendwie ein, äh, deep-loaded Firestick oder ein Shield-TV oder sonst was,
preislich zwar ein bisschen teurer, also je nachdem, entweder ähnlich teuer oder teurer sind,
aber eine Android-TV auf passende Hardware einfach viel, viel weicher ist,
die besseren Anwendungen für Media-Center hat und überhaupt besser funktioniert.
Als ein selbstgestrickter Raspberry-Pi als Media-Center.
Der Riesenvorteil von einem Android-TV ist,
dass du halt die ganzen Android-Apps verwenden kannst.
Auf einem Raspberry-Pi hast du das, fängt's ja schon an.
Wenn du auf einem Raspberry-Pi Amazon Prime-Video gucken willst oder Netflix gucken willst,
dann geht das so ohne weiteres nicht.
Auf einem Android-TV ist das überhaupt kein Problem.
Not a big fan of the stock...
Offizielle App, gut ist.
...you'll just need to right-click on any of the desktops and change the background from there.
So, on the initial boot, it'll prompt you with this setup wizard.
We're just gonna click start here.
Ja, blablabla.
...make sure you have...
...2.5.
...it's gonna...
So, jetzt zeigt mal was.
...we're now ready to use our Raspberry-Pi as an everyday desktop.
Working with both monitors is really easy to do.
There's a few options we can change by right-clicking on either desktop
and going to desktop properties.
Dazu kommt ja auch noch, dass unter Linux Chrome bzw. unter Firefox gar nicht
Hardware-Decoding von Videos funktioniert.
Das kann ich mir nicht vorstellen,
dass Netflix auf einem Raspberry-Pi in 1080p ohne Hardware-Decoding läuft.
Oder das Ding brennt hier durch den Tisch wahrscheinlich.
Das ist halt der Riesenvorteil von einem Fire Stick, einem Shield-TV,
einem Roku-TV und was es nicht alles gibt.
Die Android-TV-Dinger, die funktionieren halt einfach mit den Standard-Apps.
Und da ist auch ein ordentlicher Hardware-Decoder drauf,
der zusammen mit den Apps funktioniert.
Das ist halt von Vorteil. Selbstgestrickt.
Ich meine, es funktioniert auf keine...
Es gibt kein Firefox unter Linux, der Hardware-Decoding unterstützt von Videos.
Das ist lächerlich, dass sie das bis heute nicht gebacken bekommen haben.
Chrome gibt es Patches für und dann aber auch nur in der passenden Kombination
mit Intel-Grafikkarte bzw. mit Nvidia-Grafikkarte,
mit zusätzlichen Libraries dabei.
Und man muss entweder einen Chrome selbst bauen, das will man nicht.
Das dauert acht Stunden gefühlt, bis man mal...
Acht Stunden und irgendwie 50 GB RAM, um mal so einen Chrome zu kompilieren.
Das dauert ewig. Wirklich ewig.
Oder man nimmt irgendwas Pre-Buildetes, wo man nicht genau weiß, wo es herkommt.
Aber... Also, es ist definitiv sehr eklig.
Oh, tatsächlich haben sie es jetzt geschafft.
Ja, Wayland. Ich will aber kein Wayland verwenden.
Kann der aktuelle Firefox den Grafikkarten-H.264-Decoder verwenden?
Ja, das ist auch schon mal gut.
Dann geht es so langsam aber sicher in die richtige Richtung.
Aber es ist halt immer noch lächerlich, dass sie es bis jetzt nicht hingekriegt haben.
Die sollen...
Die sollen den Grafikkarten-H.264-Decoder verwenden, aber nicht Wayland.
Was juckt mich Wayland als Ausgabe?
Wayland ist so ein Ding, was du in 20 Jahren vielleicht mal verwenden kannst,
wenn alles funktioniert.
...which is my left screen, or HDMI 2, which will be my right screen.
There's also an option to mirror the main display in case you...
Genau. Also, im Prinzip, um das zusammenzufassen,
auch mit den Erfahrungen hier aus dem Chat, einfacher und weicher fährt man eindeutig
mit irgendeinem Display.
Es gibt eine x-beliebige Android-TV-Lösung.
Und wenn man nicht viel Geld ausgeben will,
kauft man sich für ein Apple und ein i beim Weihnachts-Sale einen Amazon Fire-TV-Stick.
...both of the displays to look exactly the same.
But the way I have mine going is kind of a dual desktop workspace area.
So I can just drag and drop different...
Kann der auch mal was zeigen?
...browser...
We are running...
...application installation...
Jetzt kommt jetzt, jetzt bin ich mal gespannt, wenn der YouTube aufmacht.
...if you don't want to.
But we are running Linux.
This is Debian ported to a Raspberry Pi, known as Raspbian.
So over on the right hand side I've just dropped Chromium.
We're going to be running a YouTube video on the right hand side.
And on the left hand side I'm going to get some work done.
Well, maybe not too much work, but...
Da schläfst du ja ein bei. Guckt euch das mal an.
...wenn I want to play Minecraft while the video is running on the right hand side.
We can utilize these dual screens to the fullest on the Raspbian Pi 4.
Boah, da kriegst du ja Ausschlag bei.
...especially if you have the 4-gigabyte model that comes with this.
Und es ruckelt! Es ruckelt!
As you can see, I got Minecraft running here.
This is the Raspberry Pi's version of Minecraft.
Es ruckelt! Seht ihr das?
...and we have a YouTube video running on the right hand side.
Das läuft mal schneller und mal langsamer.
...on the right hand side.
Now the YouTube video...
Also wer uns das hier wirklich als Desktop-Ersatz verkaufen will,
der ist nicht mehr ganz dicht.
...was actually running at 720p.
The Pi 4 is capable of doing 1080p, but there's some frame drops.
Ja.
Now, I might not notice it, but it's definitely dropping some frames.
I find that 720p works fine on the Raspberry Pi 4,
especially in 4-gigabyte. Und Minecraft wieder so ruckelt!
...we got that over on the right hand side.
Now, it's not gonna look as good as a 1080p video.
And if you're running 720p video on a giant 43-inch or a 50-inch screen,
it's not gonna look as crisp...
Das ist die Minecraft Pi Edition.
Wusste gar nicht, dass es so was gibt.
...that would on a smaller monitor like this.
I think it's perfectly acceptable to run 720p videos...
Das Ghostwriter, das reicht noch nicht mal für deine Großeltern.
Wenn du willst, dass deine Großeltern,
die eh schon keinen Bock auf Computer haben,
danach noch weniger Bock auf Computer haben,
dann gibst du denen so was.
Es ist ein Irrglaube, dass technisch wenig versierte Leute
besser mit schlechter Hardware klarkommen als technisch versierte Leute.
Es ist sogar eher so, dass technisch unversierte Leute
mehr und schneller abgefuckt sind bei schlechter Hardware,
weil es eben hängt, ruckelt und hakt
und sie wieder bestätigt sind darüber,
dadurch, dass Technik scheiße ist.
Deswegen habe ich meiner Mutter auch als erstes,
wenn es um das Thema ging, Tablets, Smartphones,
die hatten ein iPad, ein iPad 6,
also irgendein schnelles,
die hatten ein iPad und die hatten ein iPhone.
So, der Scheiß ist schnell und der Kram funktioniert auch für die größten Kacknoobs.
...a single monitor. I think it looks really good.
Wenn es läuft, sieht es gut aus.
Warum sollte es auch schlecht aussehen?
Aber es ruckelt.
As for everyday use of the Raspberry Pi 4 as, let's say, a desktop PC,
I think performance would be perfectly acceptable for most people.
If you're just one of those people who get online to check your Facebook, Reddit,
check your email, maybe do some document editing
and even light image editing, this would be perfectly acceptable.
Es hat gerade im Chat einer gefragt,
wenn ich mir auf einem Raspberry Pi 4 ein P-Hole installiere,
der Name von dieser Software macht mich jedes Mal fertig,
installiere, kann ich den Pi dann auch weiterhin verwenden
oder zieht das alle Leistung?
P-Hole braucht nichts an Leistung.
DNS braucht generell so gut wie nichts an Leistung.
Du kannst auf dem, vor allem du hast einen Raspberry Pi 4,
dieses Ding ist auch noch halbwegs geschwind.
Du kannst da drauf noch 20 andere Sachen laufen lassen,
das ist ohne jegliche Probleme.
Was die Klimaministerin meinte ja auch,
dass man nicht die beste Streamingqualität...
Oh ja, das habe ich auf Twitter gepostet.
Wartet mal, habt ihr das eigentlich gesehen?
Habt ihr das eigentlich gesehen?
Ich habe das irgendwann mal retweetet.
Ähm, ja.
Guck mal, das ist unsere Umweltministerin,
wäre das nicht...
Ich kannte die vorher gar nicht,
wusste gar nicht, dass das unsere Umweltministerin ist.
Ähm, die hat gesagt, äh,
Hallo?
Also, die hat gesagt, nicht schlechter, sondern smarter.
Ob Videos auf Handy in höchster Auflösung abgespielt werden,
nimmt das menschliche Auge nicht wahr.
Ähm, deshalb sollte die Videoqualität Standard werden,
die zum Endgerät passt, das tut nicht weh,
macht aber beim Energieverbrauch einen großen Unterschied.
Also, ich weiß nicht, was mit den Leuten irgendwie los ist.
Ich muss übrigens gerade mal Chat aufholen,
weil ich habe irgendwie nicht runtergescrollt.
Ähm...
So, also.
Das ist, das ist unglaublicher Fail.
Ähm, also, erstens macht es einen Unterschied,
in welcher Auflösung was läuft.
Allein schon durch die Bitrate macht es einen Unterschied, ja.
Also, die Bitrate von einem 1080p-Video
oder von einem 4K-Video auf YouTube ist viel, viel höher
als von einem 720p-Video.
Und gerade bei mehr FPS und schnellen Videos
ist es ein Riesenunterschied,
in welcher Auflösung ich das anzeigen muss.
Das liegt nicht direkt an der Auflösung,
das liegt an YouTube und an Streaming-Seiten,
die einfach Videos mit höherer Auflösung mehr Bandbreite geben
und verhältnismäßig mehr Bandbreite als das niedrigere Videos haben.
So.
Dazu kommt, dass, ähm, die meisten Videos, habe ich auch schon geschrieben,
die meisten schon von der App standardmäßig so eingestellt sind,
dass das Ganze dynamisch abgespielt wird.
Ähm, auf den Stromverbrauch hat das kaum, ähm, einen Einfluss,
weil die meisten Geräte,
ähm, Hardware-Decoder dafür haben.
Und dem ist das ziemlich egal, ob ich 720p oder 1080p decode.
Das macht unterm Strich, äh, also nahezu keinen Unterschied.
Ähm, Mobile-Geräte und Tablets sind eh schon auf niedrigen Energieverbrauch ausgelegt.
Das heißt, das macht den Bock echt nicht fett.
Und außerdem, das kommt ja auch noch dazu,
ist der Ausbau und die Tarife in Deutschland viel zu schlecht,
dass man, äh, eine hohe Auflösung überhaupt, äh, Streaming ohne Buffern machen kann.
So. Und da, es gibt noch einige weitere Punkte,
wo das Ganze, äh, geht.
Was die ganze Auswirkung hat, ist, äh, irgendwo im Rechenzentrum oder so, ja?
Also, wenn jetzt die Leute anfangen würden, ähm, nur noch weniger Traffic zu verursachen,
dann würde das vielleicht im Rechenzentrum ein bisschen was sparen.
Aber auch da bin ich skeptisch, wie viel das Ganze bringt.
Also, eigentlich vollkommener schwachsinniger Vorschlag.
Was macht Stadia gerade?
Nix macht Stadia.
Stadia hat jetzt angeblich Chrome Support,
und, äh, eine Final-Fantasy-DLC, der total für'n Arsch ist.
Und Stadia ist bald RIP, da geh ich auch vorn aus.
Und wohlgemerkt, ich kann's an der Stelle nicht oft genug sagen,
sie haben im Vorfeld gesagt, es wäre für sie eine Enttäuschung,
wenn sie mit Google Stadia NUR, ich betone NUR,
so viele Spieler hätten wie die PlayStation.
Nur so viele Spieler wie die PlayStation.
Wäre eine Enttäuschung.
Stadia hat 500.000 Downloads auf mobilen Endgeräten.
Ja, schön.
Kann mir auch viel runterladen, wenn der Tag lang ist.
BWL-Träume, ja.
Moin, der Patrick ist auch am Start.
Nee.
Ich mein, guck mal, wie sie da so rumruckeln, da kriegst du Anfälle.
Nein, es ist nach wie vor scheiße als Desktop-PC.
Erzählt den Leuten doch nicht so was.
Niemand wird glücklich mit einem Raspberry Pi als Desktop-PC.
Ich verdiene mein Geld mit Linux seit 13 Jahren, ja.
Also ich bin nur beim besten Mittel kein Linux-Hater und Windows-Fan.
Aber auf dem Desktop ist ein Pi mit Linux für die meisten Leute komplett für den Arsch.
... die Edition of the Raspberry Pi 4.
Performance is way up from the original Raspberry Pi.
And this could act as an everyday desktop PC for light users.
You could do your homework on here.
Und selbst für meinen Heim-Automatisierungs-Server war mir der Pi zu nervig und zu langsam.
Do your taxes on here, browse the web, check your email, write an essay.
There's a lot of stuff that can be done with the Raspberry Pi 4 like it sits as a desktop PC.
And the software is getting better and better.
Der macht ja nix, der verschiebt Fenster.
Ich mein, wenn Fenster verschieben schon nicht gehen würde, dann würde ich mich wundern.
Aber, der macht ja nix.
Das, was er uns gezeigt hat, ruckelt.
... an upgrade on that GPU driver.
There's talks about Vulkan being ported over.
... or for somebody who doesn't already have one.
... and doesn't have a laptop or a computer to work with.
... Pi 4 with its...
Muss jetzt mal kurz gucken, ob das stimmt.
Was? Ich sagte was?
Firefox, äh, was? 57 hat Hardware-Decoding.
Warum on Wayland?
Wer zum Geier möchte standardmäßig Wayland verwenden?
Zumindest aktuell.
Okay, was?
Firefox on Wayland now have full WebGL.
Okay, das ist schon mal ein Punkt.
Das ganze Working Web, PXL...
Gut, dann brauchst du natürlich erst mal eine Grafikkarte, die das Ganze unterstützt.
Das ist ja auch wieder so ein Problem, was du unter Linux hast.
Hauptsächlich Intel.
Intel funktioniert wunderbar.
Äh, Wayland ist der Display...
Oh Gott, wie erkläre ich das jetzt?
Weißt du was? X, also das...
Wayland ist der Ersatz für X.
Also quasi, ähm...
Die Schnittstelle zwischen deiner Grafikkarte und der grafischen Oberfläche.
Ist das.
Jetzt ohne Fenster, ohne Desktop, ohne Anwendung.
Einfach nur die Schnittstelle zwischen deiner Grafikkarte und der Möglichkeit,
GUI-Anwendungen darzustellen.
Ähm, da hast du wieder das Problem.
Intel funktioniert mit WAPI ganz gut.
Nvidia braucht irgendwelche Zwischen-Hacks und AMD-Geglaubige gar nicht.
Es gibt ja auch drei verschiedene Grafik-Schnittstellen für Acceleration unter Linux, ne?
Du hast, oder noch mehr, du hast die Native-Geschichten von den Herstellern.
Du hast WAPI, du hast VD, POW oder wie das heißt und noch mehr.
Die machen sich wirklich das Leben unglaublich schwer.
Es ist ja auch toll,
dass die Dinger so tolle Namen haben wie Wayland, DMA, Buff, WAPI.
Alles klar.
Das ist einer der Gründe, warum Linux auf dem Desktop nie was werden wird.
Weil man bei entscheidenden Technologien oftmals, ähm...
Also da, auf die es ankommt, wie zum Beispiel Hardware-Video-Decoding,
einfach fünf bis zehn Jahre hinterher ist und sie sich nicht einig werden.
Das ist definitiv...
Cyberlink, das ist definitiv keine angenehme User-Experience.
Gut, man kann sagen, es ist...
Die Developer-Version vom aktuellen Firefox, die darf dann auch ein bisschen unrund laufen,
aber die fertige Version wird auch nicht besser sein.
Und wisst ihr, was mir auch richtig auf den Keks geht?
Ähm, dass Funktionen entfernt werden.
Beispielsweise hatte der Firefox für Android einen Software-Video-Decoder dabei.
Hatte sogar einen H.264-Video-Codec dabei für Endgeräte,
die eben keinen gescheit funktionierenden Hardware-Decoder haben,
so wie die meisten günstigen Tablets, die im Browser dann nicht richtig funktionieren.
So.
Ähm, und ab Version 68 haben sie das rausgeschmissen, was dazu führt,
dass meine Kameraübersicht unter iOS wunderbar funktioniert,
unter Windows, Linux, Desktop auch wunderbar funktioniert,
aber unter Android gar nicht mehr funktioniert.
Chrome unter Android hat keinen Software-H.264-Decoder für Videos.
Und Firefox hat eine in Version 68 entfernt.
Das heißt, das einzige, was mir übrig bleibt, dass ich mir meine Kameras angucken kann,
auf Android ist, einen Firefox 68 zu installieren und den nicht upgraden zu lassen.
Natürlich auch geile Lösung, super.
Dieses Rumgefuddel geht mir einfach nur auf den Keks.
Und da habe ich keinen Bock mehr drauf.
Wo sind wir denn jetzt eigentlich stehen geblieben?
Nirgendwo, oder? Wir waren fertig mit dem Video.
Hat Firefox Preview einen Decoder, ähm,
ähm, anscheinend nicht, nee.
Es ging mir jetzt ja auch um die Android-Variante.
Ach, das ist alles so ein Minenfeld, ey.
Es ist nicht so, dass Apple überall besser wäre, ja.
Gar nicht.
Der PWA-Support unter iOS ist eine Krankheit, ja.
Die bekleckern sich da alle nicht mit Ruhm.
Firefox Preview auf Android, nee, hat bestimmt keinen Decoder, glaube ich nicht.
Die dürfen das nicht mehr vertreiben über den Store mit dem Decoder.
Weil Google gesagt hat, gibt's nicht.
Aber anstatt zu sagen, okay, wir bieten ein Bild an,
was ihr euch selbst installieren könnt, was diesen Decoder dabei hat,
gibt's ihn jetzt gar nicht mehr.
Das ist alles so Frickelware.
Das ist alles so Rumgefrickel, ey.
Leute, ich glaube, ich gehe jetzt Mittagessen.
Ich habe übelst Hunger.
Und ich muss mal aufs Klo.
Also, ich habe mir aufgeschrieben, was wir als Nächstes noch ausprobieren,
ist, wir probieren den Windows-10x-Emulator aus.
Ähm.
Wir installieren uns mal Android auf dem Raspberry Pi 4.
Das wollte ich schon eine Weile ausprobieren.
Einfach mal gucken, ob das halbwegs funktioniert.
Ähm, nee, ich glaube nicht, dass man damit was Sinnvolles tun kann.
Aber einfach nur mal zu gucken.
Ähm, ja.
Und jetzt noch mal hier so als für die Leute,
die sich einen Raspberry Pi als Mediacenter bauen wollten.
Guckt einfach mal, ob es einen Fire-TV-Stick wieder gibt.
Guckt mal.
Aktuell.
Es gab 29,99.
Der Scheiß ist billiger als ein Raspberry Pi 4.
Und für Mediacenter um Längen besser geeignet als ein Raspberry Pi 4.
Machst du Amazon-Deep-Loading und gut ist es.
Also, da scheißt halt der Raspberry Pi dagegen ab.
Fire-TV-Stick ruckelt wie Sau, ja, aber weniger als Android.
Äh, weniger, weniger als der Raspberry Pi.
Am besten ist eh, also wenn ihr...
Das beste Mediacenter ist nach wie vor das Shield TV.
Oh.
Das neue Shield TV ist ja dieser komische Zigarettenanzünder.
Was ist mit denen eigentlich los hier?
Was ist das für eine Fern...
Warum ist denn die Fernbedienung jetzt auf einmal dreieckig?
Warum ist die Fernbedienung jetzt dreieckig?
Die machen da auch laufend irgendwas anderes, äh.
Und dann so ein komischer Zigarettenanzünder draus gemacht.
Also ich hab den da noch hier.
Da gab's ja auch...
Da hatte ich ja auch mal ein Video zu gemacht.
Ein Video, wo ich mich auch mal wieder, mal wieder spiegel.
Und wo man mich, und wo man mich hier irgendwo...
Pass mal auf, da ist es.
Ja.
Das ist ja das, was ich aktuell dran hab.
Mit Nvidia-Ente.
Ich hab sogar, übrigens ich hab sogar Nvidia-Schuhe, fällt mir grad bei der Gelegenheit ein, als wo ich das Video wieder seh.
Ich weiß nicht so genau, warum ich überhaupt Video Nvidia-Schuhe hab, aber ich hab Nvidia-Schuhe.
Ähm...
Und hier haben sich, sind sie wieder alle ausgeflippt, weil ich mich spiegel.
Hier, guck.
Ja.
Hintergrund, jetzt gespiegelt.
Und wenn er, und wenn der Bildschirm schwarz wird zwischenzeitlich, dann sieht man mich richtig gut.
Wenn man irgendwo mal ne, ne Stelle findet, wo der Bildschirm schwarz wird.
Hier, guck mal.
Man sieht mich.
Leaked.
Jetzt erst mal den CSI-Zoom rausholen.
Enhanced Zoom.
Hehehe.
Leaked.
Monkatos.
Ja.
Man sieht, manche Stellen sieht man mich sogar noch besser.
Hier.
Hehehe.
Mit dem Mikrofon nebendran.
Und...
Also das Ding kann ich empfehlen.
Das aktuelle Shield-TV weiß ich nicht.
Ähm, vor allem, warum ist das, warum ist das grad so teuer?
Das wird ja jedes Jahr teurer.
WTF?
Ja, 130 kann ich eher mit leben.
Der Fire-TV Cube.
Die haben ja zig, zigtausend Sachen, ja.
Aber das beste Mediacenter ist tatsächlich das, das Shield-TV.
Das läuft so weich da drauf, wie gesagt, ich hab's ja seit Jahren schon jetzt.
Top.
Kann man echt nix sagen.
Hehehe.
Ab aktuell ein Pi mit LibreLX würdest du sagen, ein Fire-TV ist besser.
Wenn du mit dem Pi zufrieden bist, ne.
Wenn du mit dem Pi nicht zufrieden bist, dann auf jeden Fall.
Man muss ja nix, man muss nix, äh, umbauen, wo, wo nix ist, was einen stört, ja.
Was gibt's gleich zu essen?
Wahrscheinlich Nudeln.
Nächster Stream dann mit Facecam.
Ah, yes.
Ich hab doch euch letztens...
Weinkeller.
Ich hab euch doch schon letztens das Bild aus meinem Weinkeller gezeigt.
Ich find's nicht mehr.
Wo ist das Bild aus meinem Weinkeller?
Weg, weg ist es.
Hast du Nudeln gebunkert?
Hey, ich hab doch schon gesagt, ich hab immer nen Schrank halb voller Nudeln da.
Immer, egal ob Corona oder nicht Corona.
Ich hab auch meine Heimwerker, äh, Atemschutzmaske, mit, mit Antivirenfiltern, da kann mir nix passieren.
Und mein Speer gegen Eindringlinge.
Wenn hier einer der Meinung ist, meine Vorräte plündern zu müssen, dann wird er mit dem Speer vertrieben.
Weiß nicht, warum das den Chat immer so erheitert, wenn ich sag, ich hab nen Speer an der Treppe liegen.
Ja, hast du auch genug Klopapier?
Ja, hab ich auch, ich hab sechs Packungen noch.
Speer gleich Zahnschale?
Nein, ich hab nen Zaunpfahl.
Ich hab schon gesagt, so nen zwei Meter langen Zaun, Stück von nem Zaun, von so nem spitzen Zaun.
Das ist aber halt ein Speer im Endeffekt.
Das ist halt ein langes, langes, dünnes Stück Metall mit ziemlich langer Spitze dran.
Das heißt, da gibt's dann in your face, wenn hier einer versucht, meine Vorräte zu plündern.
Gehst du damit jagen, ne?
Ne, wenn ich, mal angenommen, Corona wird so schlimm, dass ich jagen muss.
Wenn ich jagen gehen muss, dann nehm ich mal ne Armbrust.
Ich hab ne Armbrust.
Auch schon ne ganze Weile.
Eine Tactical Armbrust.
Tactical Crossbow.
Den Tomahawk hab ich mir nicht gekauft, ne.
Also ich mein, was soll da schon schiefgehen, ja?
Ne Speer und ne Tactical Armbrust.
Also mehr, da kann nix mal schiefgehen.
Da bin ich für alles gerüstet.
Gehst du noch raus?
Natürlich nicht, ich geh nie raus.
Tactical Nuke, hahaha, ja die fehlt noch.
Was zockst du momentan?
Eigentlich nur Pass of Exile.
Armbrust Akimbo, das hab ich noch nicht ausprobiert.
Ich hab auch nur eine.
Aber man könnte das so Demon Hunter Style machen, so quasi den Speer in der einen Hand,
Armbrust in der anderen Hand.
Wobei die Armbrust, also die ist ziemlich scheiße einhändig zu halten, ne?
Also so cool, wie sie das dann in irgendwelchen Filmen machen, so aus der Hüfte mit der Armbrust,
irgendwie über 20 Kilometer, die Leute, ist damit nicht.
Gucken wir mal, das bei Amazon findet das Ding.
Ja, Tactical Armbrust, Tactical Armbrust, ah das ist nur Aufsatz.
Also es ist ja gar keine Tactical Armbrust, es ist einfach nur ne Armbrust.
Darf man sowas überhaupt haben?
Ne, sowas, das ist das alles nicht.
Die sieht ein bisschen hochwertiger aus.
Wie dem auch sei, wurscht.
Ähm, du bist auf Purge vorbereitet, man muss auf, besser haben als später, äh,
brauchen, ja?
Gut Leute, ich geh jetzt aufs Klon, dann geh ich was essen.
Wir sehen uns im nächsten Stream.
Schauen was wir dann machen.
Wie gesagt, entweder, entweder den Raspberry Pi mit Android, oder den Windows 10x Emulator mal ausprobieren.
Wir sehen uns, machts gut.
Äh, wie kann ich den hosten, Leute? Habt ihr ne Ahnung?
Du folgst, mal gucken ob einer online ist von denen, denen ich, äh, ups, ich hab grad mein Headset runtergeschmissen.
Test, Test, ja.
Irgendwie keiner da.
Der Krieger ist on.
Wir können den Krieger hosten.
Der spielt Modern Warfare, äh, Blackout.
Oh Gott, Blackout, hör mal auf.
Bloß nicht.
Hast du Angst vor Corona nicht wirklich?
In meinem Alter hab ich gute Chancen es zu überleben.
Komm, wir hosten den Krieger.
Der hat mich letztens auch gehostet.
Also Leute, wir sehen uns.
Erstmal Raid.
Also, bis zum nächsten Mal.
Wir sehen uns, CU.